working together for the common good and
for the benefit of all the people
now i could reminisce about the harmony
of the the great famine relief
phenomenon of the mid 1980s
live aid or i could remind us of the
last time we saw on our news screens
people digging through the night to find
earthquake survivors that they'd never
met
but probably the best example i could
offer right now is the remarkable global
effort
to combat covid19 we've not seen
anything like this before
in terms of its scale its duration or
its global impact
there's nothing like facing a common
enemy to foster a sense of harmony
in the letter to the romans we read this
bless those who persecute you
bless and do not curse rejoice with
those who rejoice
mourn with those who mourn live in
harmony with one another
do not be proud but be willing to
associate with people of low position
do not be conceited do not repay anyone
evil for evil
be careful to do what is right in the
eyes of everyone
if it is possible as far as it depends
on you
live at peace with everyone
now as ever uh whether you're a person
of faith or not
uh we're going to take a moment now if
you're not a prayerful person that's
absolutely fine but please use these
brief moments to think and reflect on
these
matters in your own way let's pray
our father in heaven help us to live in
harmony by showing love for each other
help us to lay aside our differences our
preferences
and our personal desires and remember
that we're called to serve the needs of
others
and not ourselves and when we do feel
agitated and discordant
help us to remember to see the other
person as a person
just a human being like us with the same
feelings and the same failings that we
have
help us not to think of ourselves more
highly than we ought but instead to
consider other people as better than
ourselves
under john's wisdom and impartial
chairing please direct
and guide this council to lay aside both
personal preference and party politics
wherever
a spirit of oneness would be preferable
for everyone's sake
we thank you for hearing our prayers for
feeding us with your word
and encouraging us in our meeting
together in jesus name
amen amen mark thank you for those very
thoughtful words thank you very much
indeed
we're now live streaming thank you for
that thank you uh could we have a roll
call please
councillor barrel austin
councillors councillor bradford
president
president councillor clarence president
councillor colclough present
she's presented her apologies
if you remember at the last fall council
thank you yeah
councillor david cox present
councillor hughcocks prison
councillor doors i'm here
counselor hirst present
councillor evans present
cancer goodman bradbury president
councillor gribble present
council haynes present
that's the haze
that's the haze
cancer jeffries present cancer jinx
councillor jenks
cancer keeling present cancer care as
well
present cancer mcgregor
present catherine morgan president
catherine alone present cancer natalie
president
present cancer
counselor orm
cancer parker calm present
cancer patch present
cancer pitt prison
council linda pedreck present
cancer fips present
cancer present
counselor rolison president
council russell answer swain
present councillor taylor president
cancer thorne president cancer two
councillor two
councillor wrigley president
council parker present councillor john
pedrick
thank you very much indeed just a few
points on today's meeting protocols
um please ensure your microphone is on
mute if you're not speaking
also keep your camera on during the
actual meeting
should a comfort break be required which
is normally at the one and a half hour
point
and i'll make a judgment when we get
close to that time members are asked to
switch both camera and microphone off
for the break period
should you wish to comment on on
anything and wish to address the council
please raise your electronic hand they i
am a co-host and they appear on my
screen in the sequence that you actually
raise your hand so
you actually form an order eq as such
are there any apologies for absence
as well as counselor cook i've got
councillor eden and councillor
foden okay thank you for that sir
thank you sorry could you also add uh i
know council two was trying to get in
he's away on business
but he's trying to get in so could you
extend his apologies as well please
thank you for that could i um chris
jenks has just contacted me he can't get
away from work
so he's sending his apologies okay thank
you thank you
any any more okay thank you for that
so item two the minutes to approve
as a correct record and sign and the
minutes of the previous meeting which
was held on the 22nd of february
do i have a proposal please
i'll propose chairman thank you
councillor connor and
the second year
uh councillor councilor nutley was there
a split second before you go to the cops
so could we go to the vote please on
that beth
council austin oh i'm sorry sorry a
second i do apologize
see councillor mcgregor has raised his
blue hand council mcgregor
thank you chair sorry about that it was
just that my understanding of the
protocol was normally to ask whether
everybody
uh or anybody had any any uh comments
regarding the minutes first okay
my only my only point was that in in the
minutes it says that
the motion presented regarding standards
at the last full council meeting
would be referred back to full council
or sorry to executive from full council
and it hasn't been referred back to
executive it's going to the new
committee which we did
detailed later which i think was
actually the point that was discussed
previously
so it was just uh to say whether that
could be adjusted to show that it's
going to this new
new committee are you okay with that
sarah
um it will go to executive who will then
um
make a decision as to where they want to
refer it and
um you know if they refer to the new
procedures committee
um or straight back up to council that
will be for executive
but it will that's how it is in a minute
okay thank you
i see that councillor pat has also
raised his hand councillor patch
thank you chairman um similar to council
mcgregor's point
my notice of motion at the last full
council um was
um according to the minutes um to be
referred to executive now there has been
at least one executive meeting since
then um and it wasn't on the agenda
and um i'm just wondering what the um
plan is for dealing with that
um in light of the possible new
arrangements
uh would you mind commenting on that
please leader oh you are thank you
thank you chairman i apologize
councillor patch wasn't aware i thought
we'd explained
um the executive had no way to refer the
motion
until council considers the creation of
a procedures committee today
if procedures committee is approved by
council we will have some way to
refer councillor patch's motion to uh
for it to be considered and that's why
it wasn't on the agenda of the executive
at the last meeting
thank you may i ask you some
clarification please chair my
understanding is that the executive
could actually discuss it and then refer
it to council for consideration
chairman in light of the fact that
council was also considering a
procedures committee
it seemed entirely appropriate to hold
it in order they went to the group of
members
who were tasked with the job of looking
at that so that's why it was done
uh and and for quite proper reasons
thank you chairman thank you leader
right can we now go to the vote please
beth
councillor austin
council austin four
council bradford abstain
council bill event
councilor clarence paul cancer colclough
council connet
council david cox oh councillor hugh cox
councillor dawes zayn
councillor dewhurst oh council evans
or council goodman bradbury
for cancer gribble or
councillor haynes
or councillor hayes
or cancer hocking
or cancer gordon hook
or that's a jackie hook
counselor jeffrey councillor jeffries
for councillor keeling
for cancer care as well oh
cancer mcgregor or
cancer morgan oh
captain malone staying
captain natalie yeah cancer
parker or cancer john patheric
that's carried chair thank you for that
sarah
item three announcements i have a few
announcements today
following the sad passing of his royal
highness the prince philip duke of
edinburgh
there was a national book of condolences
opened that uh
book is still open and there is a link
on the team bridge council website
should anyone wish to offer their
condolences
sadly i've also heard today of the two
recent deaths of former councillors
jane stoven passed away on the 20th of
january
2021 she was a district council in the
early 90s
and also richard bassett who passed away
on the 16th of april
2021. he was a councillor in the
1999-2003
council period for the former powder
award i'm sure members who will join me
in passing on our condolences to their
families and friends thank you
when i was elected chair of team bridge
in july last year
i nominated east team bridge community
transport as my chosen charity
i had hoped at the time to raise a few
thousand pounds
but appreciated it would be difficult
during a pandemic
it was suggested that the money raised
should be contributed to a new vehicle
fund
the cost of this specially adapted
wheelchair accessible vehicle
would be about 67 000 pounds which is
quite an ambitious target
donations began trickling in some some
as many as a few hundred pounds the
local press publicised the fundraising
initiative and team bridge
communications
covered the item in a residence
newsletter about six weeks ago i had a
call from a resident of team bridge
who wished to remain anonymous he
advised that he had seen the team which
residents newsletter
and wished to make a sizeable donation
which he would gift aid
within two days a substantial amount of
money was transferred to east team
bridge community transport
we now have enough money to purchase a
new specially adapted minibus for 67
000 pounds so thank you very much that
anonymous donor
finally um congratulations are in order
for mr ollie watkins who is a team
bridge resident
who has been chosen to play for england
i understand that he recently
scored a goal and i understand that also
counselor hook would like to say a few
words about this young man
thank you very much mr chairman i'm
grateful for you
granting me that privilege um
i think it's absolutely right to praise
and and rejoice in success
local people do succeed and it is
possible even coming from devon
to reach the very top in a given
profession or pursuit
ollie watkins is a success by any
standard
educated at decoy primary school in in
newton norbert and and in
south dartmoor college ashburton he is
therefore
a local boy he doesn't live in
devon any longer he's got a palatial
proud no doubt in in the birmingham area
but but he's a local boy local educated
only last summer he obtained a 30
million pound transfer
from brighton uh from brentford football
club where he'd gone
from exeter football club to aston villa
sufficient success for some of us in
itself
but recently he made a scoring debut as
you've alluded to
for the on his debut for the england
team he is quite obviously a very good
footballer
and from my limited knowledge a good
role model
by which i mean he isn't a play actor he
doesn't fall over at a puff of wind
trying to con rest he's a team man
and i like loyal team men he gives of
his best
and is a 100 trier an admiral
admirable role model i would suggest for
aspiring youngsters
now i don't care much if it's success in
sport football or
or the arts or science or whatever
let's celebrate achievement and in so
doing say to every youngster
in team bridge and in devon dream your
dreams
aspire to achieve and if you aim for the
sun and only hit the moon well
you will have done your best and that's
not about ambition in life
local ollie watkins did it from devon
and so can you
thank you mr chairman thank you
councillor hook
item four are there any declarations of
interest please
sorry come to the doors you've raised
your hand i do apologize for not coming
to you
yeah no sorry i just wanted to follow on
if i could because uh
i've had some uh experience with all the
watkins directly
and uh if it was okay just to say a
couple of words
sure sure yes yes so uh so of course
ollie watkins was a
decoy school and uh the experience that
i had with him was when he was running a
training event with extra city football
club where he was the
star striker and the uh the treasured
photograph we have in our house is the
uh the award he gave my daughter on that
day
uh iska college so uh but also i'm a
member of extra city football club which
is community owned and uh and i know
that his transfer from brentford
and then through to aston villa football
club
uh caused a huge windfall for extra city
so the pyramid system that has been
threatened so much
uh over the last few days is in full
flow and working properly so i think we
should all take pride in that
in exeter city for being community owned
and celebrate ollie watkins successes
uh hopefully he will score the winning
goal in the euros
this summer thank you councillors thank
you very much for that comment
uh any declarations of interest item
four
no public questions we have one public
question today
um from dr richard ward can you hear me
dr dr ward
yes i can chairman thank you okay so
you've actually
presented a question to the um executive
member for economy and jobs and you
received a response i understand today
yes
yes i have yes so do you have a
supplementary question
but should actually link in with the
original question that you asked
yes thank you very much for your
response um we did have
three very very helpful meetings with
councillor connect
neil blaney and tom butcher and louise
brinton
um but the the the member the
memorandum of understanding that came
through from tom butcher didn't seem to
reflect
um what we felt the meetings had
achieved
so assuming that we can come to um an
agreement over that memorandum of
understanding
how will the we carry on with the
discussions
as promised uh in what sort of forum and
in what form please thank you councillor
jeffries would you like to respond now
or respond in a later date in writing
um thank you dr ward for your
supplementary question
um i'd like to provide a written
response at a later date if that's okay
given the nature of your question i
think we need to
have um give it you course
and um come back to you with a written
response if that's okay
yes that would be that would be very
helpful thank you very much thank you
very much
thank you dr ward uh you you're welcome
just to
to sit in our waiting room now our
virtual waiting room and enjoy the rest
of the meeting if you'd like
but i suspect you've got other things
beginning on with okay
well thank you very much for your time
that's very kind thank you thank you sir
goodbye
uh there aren't any cancer questions
so recommendations from committees this
is item seven on the agenda
recommendation from the executive
notice a motion to acknowledge the work
that the voluntary and charitable sector
do
particularly but not exclusively during
the current coronavirus
pandemic and i understand that the
leader will move this recommendation
thank you chairman i formally moved the
recommendation to council from executive
and defend now to the secondary council
of gordon hook who was the
prime mover of a motion thank you
absolutely yes
thank you mr chairman um and thank um
thank you leader i i very much welcome
the executive recommendations which are
set out before
us and i won't read them through because
they're all there for
for members to have seen prior to the
meeting
i sincerely hope for cross-chamber
unanimous support for those
recommendations in the spirit of harmony
and one ship which we were only recently
reminded of ladies and gents counselors
we have witnessed firsthand the simply
outstanding exemplary work
undertaken by numerous volunteers across
the district
in the last 15 months or so with help
given to our communities by
by volunteers sometimes working within
organized groups
sometimes working alone but all striving
to help overcome the worst
impacts of coronavirus i am sure that
you knowing your communities will
acknowledge that and recognize
people or groups within your communities
for whom
that that is appropriate sometimes
they've been providing meals for
hundreds
sometimes simply doing the shopping for
the next door neighbor
i'm certain it is right for this
authority to acknowledge
and place on record its huge gratitude
for all those efforts uh by one and all
whether in a group or whether
individually motivated it would be wrong
however
it would be wrong however to suggest
that all charitable voluntary work had
been simply the product
of the devastating health crisis of the
last 15 months
great work again by individuals small
groups and larger organizations is and
has been going on
year in year out virtually always
unheralded and unnoticed
except by the recipients of the of the
good works
that will continue i am sure and i am
similarly sure no one
does it for thanks or personal glory
my point is that we should recognize in
the long term the ongoing and dedicated
work
of so many on behalf of our residents
that may be with regard to covid but
equally work over a period of time with
the young and the old with sport in
in the arts could be scouts and guides
the wi to say
the list is potentially endless and in
my opinion the local authority
we have a duty to encourage recognize
and thank one and all the least we can
do therefore is explore the
possibilities
which is essentially the fourth point of
a fourth
uh recommendation coming forward and see
how best on a regular
probably annual basis say a collective
thank you and in so doing
recognize and encourage such activity
i have many ideas myself
uh councillor hook you've frozen
mid-sentence
um i see that we have um
a proposal and it's been seconded
um and we have one lonely blue hand
which is george gribble word on george
for
mastering the art of the blue hand yes
thank you chairman um if i may comment
sir i i think you know sort of this is
all very good
but i would comment on on um item four
actually
uh thank you and congratulation event um
should be um
to be held uh well well i agree with
that entirely but uh
i think previously the previously uh the
previous administration
we had um a sports and personality
awards every year
i'm sorry i'm gonna have to interrupt
you but sorry you've gone back three
items is that right
no i'm i'm i'm on it from seven okay
sorry
okay number four sorry
yes okay okay yeah understood okay um
yes well i i i just think that um the
previous administration ran this
sports and uh personality awards which
was very well received throughout team
bridge
and and in the event that ollie watkins
um
can't be no appreciate appreciated by
team bridge in particular in this way i
i do agree with uh
the congratulations that we're being
sent to him and um
and and very well done but well i i
would like to see the reinstatement
of the cambridge sports and personality
awards
uh for all ages for both young and the
elderly because a lot of people are
involved in sport and it keeps them fit
thank you very much sharon thank you
councillor gribble i see that uh
gordon hook is actually back with us
again would you like to continue gordon
thank you
thank you mr i don't know what happened
there i i it's my fault i apologize i
don't think it was
i'm not sure where i got to um i i
had i had i said that for instance um
um this work of this voluntary work
wasn't just a question of
covid inspired it was also very much an
ongoing
year on year out exhibition of goodwill
by
by our residents and i do believe that
um irrespective of kovid
uh we should be looking to to thank um
those who who give of their time
voluntarily whether it be
sports arts scouts guides wi
i i suggested there was a whole range of
possibilities and
um we would all know within our
communities
those individuals and those groups who
are contributing
in this way i i believe that as we
progress in the next coming years the
voluntary sector will play
a larger rather than a smaller part in
our lives
and the good will of people is to be
encouraged
and applauded
i think the least we can do in
encouraging this activity is
is to explore the possibilities which is
what's laid out in the fourth
recommendation from the executive uh to
say a collective thank you and in so
doing
you know recognize and encourage such
activity
it's not an original concept some local
authorities already
do similar to this and of course the
state does this twice
yearly team bridge should say thank you
i believe and i sincerely hope we can
see the benefits of this proposal i i
could go on and make a lot of
suggestions
i will refrain from doing that you may
have heard some of them already i don't
know where we are with this but
um we have the the uh the sports awards
which um
the cv epidemic rather interrupted over
the last 12 months
but i'm sure that will continue that's
good um i just think that this is
another area where we as a local
authority
could be encouraging um and
encouragement is a great thing
um so i i very much hope for and look
for cross chamber
unanimous support and thank you for and
i apologize for the interruptions that
inevitably
occurred okay thank you thank you very
much indeed council
i see there are a few blue hands uh
considered boulevard
thank you i totally endorsed the uh the
spirit of what
council hook has suggested and uh
i think it's important to remember that
the last of
the community or sports and community
award ceremonies that took place
took place in 2018 and i
recognize the contribution that the
people made
and were recognized at those uh those
awards ceremonies
that were held over in their daulish and
i
certainly would think that that is a
suitable
uh vehicle for carrying forward our wish
to recognize
the people making uh contributions to
our communities
and that's something we should put in
place it's sad that we haven't seen that
take place and it was cancelled
prior to the um or delayed prior to the
start of the pandemic but i'd certainly
support the reintroduction of that as
being a suitable um
vehicle for recognition thank you thank
you councillor
councillor dawes
hi thank you um yeah i'd agree with much
of what uh
what gordon gordon said uh i deplored
the efforts uh across the sector i
i i'd rail in a little bit the idea of
needing
uh an award ceremony uh i'd be more in
favor if we can do everything we can to
stop homelessness which clearly is a
political choice
that we managed to solve during the
pandemic uh i applaud working across
community groups uh and i i like
councillor hook's uh
suggestion that we have some cross uh
chamber agreement on
on matters i'm still perplexed as to why
we can't have any cross-chamber input
into the future of the alex when
our group has the largest skills in the
area we've been shut out of any of those
conversations
so i'm finding that that difficult to
understand but uh
i i would also have uh issues with point
four on
the recommendation in terms of award
ceremonies
okay thank you councillor dawes
councillor cox david cox
thank you chairman i did attend the
sports on behalf of the voluntary
secretary
um the sports and community awards and
whilst they're wonderful when they
should carry on i think the danger of
tacking on
community and voluntary to the sports
awards was actually a mistake
and in some ways by having a winner
we're sort of saying there's also
obviously inevitably losers
which is great in sport but it isn't
great in the voluntary sector and the
voluntary sector is so
it's so wide and and during the pandemic
you know
bullivan councillor lots of councillors
took part in helping out people
who were not uh normally uh part of a
regular volunteering thing and it was i
think a great credit to this district
uh that we had so many people in fact
have to turn away volunteers at some
point for christmas day
uh doing things um councillor um
whilst he was chairman uh councillor
keeling up did um
did a um an award ceremony for the
people who received the um
uh the nhs award the voluntary sector
group
now that was not a winner take all that
was a celebration of people who
had passed a test i do wonder if that
could be the basis of a
thank you to um just invite
representatives all the voluntary groups
not have a winner not
have a loser and just just a little
reception at old ford house with the
chairman your good self
uh of the council to say thank you for
all the work you do
and you know team which is pretty good
at working with the voluntary sector
but if we could keep working with the
voluntary center that's great because we
can achieve more together we
certainly can apart i do understand
there are
uh but probably the council officers
think we're all anarchists in the
voluntary sector
um but uh uh and we run on shoestring
but you know the voluntary sector has
done a lot of good
for uh this district and i'm very
pleased that it was supported
very heavily during during the pandemic
it was given uh finance and support to
do
to do its job so i thank i thank the
council for that
but i don't think tacking on i think the
sports personality
awards game is a great scheme but it is
great for sports clubs
uh it's not really good for community
groups and they should have a separate
thank you that is not isn't necessarily
a winner a winner a winning
uh winning a prize just a little
reception to say thank you you're
appreciated
okay thank you councillor cox council
mcgregor
thank you um i just want to
correct a couple of misconceptions that
have been fired out by
um one of the group's um members um
the delay in the um
last sport and community awards that
were due to be held in 2019 were because
we had to start tightening our belt due
to the fiscal ineptitude of the previous
administration
we've done that um mcgregor yeah
on a second i'm gonna i've moved away i
know that you you know what i was about
to say was
councilman mcgregor you're being
political i don't want you to be
political please
no i'm just so clear i've i've moved the
wrong to criticize the previous
administration
yeah i've moved away from that if you
let me i will tell you you could
apologize if you wanted to next the next
misconception is that we didn't do a
sport and community awards since 2018
which is fundamentally
a falsehood we delivered it by
uh virtual means and it was it's
available on youtube
and we gave sport and community awards
in 2020
and we will probably follow the same
line this year
in in the process that we are trying to
get our leisure centers back up and
running
and we won't have the space to get
people into a
location so we'll probably do similar
again this year
and we will be doing the sport and
community awards so we haven't cancelled
it we haven't
stopped doing it it's being delivered
it's actually online
the evidence is there and i would
appreciate if
perhaps people would not present
false um uh positions that's that's your
that's your interpretation
question i'm delivering we need to move
on please
okay council of peart uh thank you chair
i did nominate somebody uh this last
year
for the sports award and this is our
local boxing club and indeed he did win
the category
but i was a little bit disappointed that
there was no certificate or anything
issued which he could put up in the
boxing club
for the rest of the boxes to see it
would have been nice to have some kind
of paper or some kind of plaque
recognition
it's not a criticism but it would have
been nice
to encourage the rest of the squad and
anybody else who entered
thank you thank you councillor piert
council dewhurst you very much
chair um so i completely agree with
councillor hook's uh motion here um
and i very much take on board the
comments of councillor cox
um regarding the difference between
sports
and volunteering in the sense that one
has a winner
and and with the other uh everybody is a
winner
and i'd particularly like to just
mention
uh a woman called ella who stood up
to fly tippers uh the day before
yesterday
in ugg brook uh reported them to the
police
uh one lone woman against a number of
men
fly tipping in a quiet country lane this
is the kind of
the kind of uh things that
all too often just get missed
and i'd just like to personally say a
massive thanks
to her for doing that and if the council
can
find these people we will come down on
them
thank you chair leader of council
um thank you chairman i just wanted to
try and restore
what this motion is about actually this
motion is about celebrating voluntary
community organizations
and the sterling workers so many people
groups and individuals
join this pandemic this most awful
tragedy that's befallen us
and the globe and and frankly i'm a
little bit astonished that uh councillor
gribble started the
uh sort of extension of that to the
sports awards there's a place in that
conversation it's somewhere different to
this
can we just focus on actually remarking
ourselves and the residents of
teambridge and the organizations the
voluntary groups
about the sterling work that they have
done that's the focus
for this thank you chairman thank you
leader thank you for clarification uh
councillor linda pedrick
thank you chair um i think it's a
wonderful idea
not actually sure about giving awards
because who would you choose
each and every volunteer you know makes
a massive contribution when i used to
work for red cross
on an annual basis and i would
organize an event for all the volunteers
they paid for nothing
um the management used to meet up with
them we used to have a lovely evening
where they
networked and they also shared good
practice and ideas
they were fed and they had they were
watered
and they had lots of positivity
towards them so i'm not sure about
giving out awards but i do agree with
doing an event for them to show our
appreciation
thank you councillor president
councillor doors
thank you uh it's just coming back on uh
a couple of the comments i'm i'm
perplexed as to why
uh the chair would accuse a politician
of being political that's exactly his
role
we're in a period of uh we're trading on
the toes of purdue if we are political
and i i wonder why uh why the leader
would uh would censor councillor gribble
for for putting forward an opinion in
in a debate it just seems uh seems some
sort of totalitarian
approach that's unhealthy thank you
thank you for that
councillor kurzweil thank you chairman
um i agree that there are many many um
volunteers who have done sterling work
throughout this
pandemic in particular and
i'm quite in favor i think of
um acknowledging these people
and i do like the idea of a small
reception
at old ford house i think that's um
that wouldn't cost a lot of money people
would be appreciated
and i think that may be a nice way to go
as for the sports personality awards
i was lucky enough when i was chairman
of the council
to go to one at langston cliff hotel
it was absolutely marvellous
that it was heaving with people
everybody
made it into a very very special
occasion
from the nominees to the people that won
and obviously the hotel did wonderful
trade so for business it was very good
and i don't see why we cannot still have
our sports personality awards plus a
reception
for volunteers who have done sterling
work
at old ford house thank you chairman
thank you councillor
kurzweil councillor rolison
thank you chair um i wholeheartedly
support
uh councillor hooks uh uh
notice emotion here it is extremely
valuable and important that we
do recognize the contributions of the
voluntary sector
the charitable sector and indeed the
individuals that have come
forward and made things happen where
or they never happened before to get us
through this pandemic it's a phenomenal
effort from my perspective um we should
acknowledge
these people in their own right not take
it on to any other event
and i really am i really would imagine
that members would have the political
acumen to not mix this up with politics
and squabbling because
the voluntary sector nor the public
going to be terribly interested in that
what they're amazed at and truly
grateful for
is the fantastic effort from the
community to beat this virus
and to see a load of politicians
squabbling absolutely you're letting
yourself dance mate so uh
that's my point of view let's get an
event it shouldn't be a competitive
event
should be for everybody that contributed
whether i can attend it or not so
thank you chairman and thank you council
revolution thank you very much
councillor hayes ash thank you chairman
i've been involved in uh voluntary work
for over 10 years way before i was a
counselor
serving the community and i can speak on
our behalf by saying
we don't need any applause we don't need
any awards we do it because we care
a simple thanks is just all we need and
that's all i've got to say really thank
you
thank you very much come to the patch
thank you chairman i would echo the
sentiments of the last speaker and other
speakers that um
that there are an awful lot of um
voluntary organizations who operate um
outside of pandemics and within
pandemics
and i i think it would be um remiss if
we were to single out
uh one or two or three or four however
many um
of those those people who've worked very
hard over the last year or so
and not to mention others um but i just
also wanted to um
sort of come back on you the chip mr
chair you you raised the issue of
peridot and um how that affects
how we are allowed to debate um within
this council meeting which i think is a
significant issue
um my understanding was that it affects
officers and team bridge communications
in particular
i'm not sure it affects um our debate i
wonder if you could share your
understanding of how purder affects our
debates in this meeting and perhaps if
we could have a comment from legal
services on that well i'm i'm happy for
legal services to say that no
could legal services please uh advise us
about kurpurda
thank you um yes
so there seems to be some confusion from
members from some of the comments that
being made
but um the council is discouraged
bearing in mind the law on the matter
from promoting
um any particular party or candidate
and that is by means of any
communication which can be
obviously through publication of
effectively this meeting
so members are asked to obviously have
due care and attention
to avoid debates becoming unduly
political where they
whether council could be seen to be
promoting a particular party
or a particular candidate and that
doesn't necessarily
affect the fact that we don't have an
election but clearly there are elections
close by
thank you thank you for that uh
for clarification then are we not
allowed to make any
um points as councillors that might be
deemed political
councillor patch uh i mean i've stopped
a member who was criticizing another
group quite openly
and i think that was wrong that was my
interpretation
but then you allowed another member to
make the same point but in a slightly
less
confrontational way well i i don't want
to get into debate by this cancer patch
i'm sorry i'm the chairman of this
committee and i've made a decision
councillor hawking
yeah thank you mr chairman um i just
wanted to um
support uh cancer hayes uh on his
um understanding of how uh
how people out there who do volunteer
work
um see how they do the volunteer work
and why um
it is quite clear to me that people who
volunteer do it because they want to
volunteer
because they want to help this help the
society help their neighbors help
community um my worry is that if we
if we have an event and i'm quite happy
to support to support
the three first one two and three of the
recommendations um i am not so happy in
supporting
number four i believe that um where
where do you draw the line who do you
invite
um you know a neighbor of mine who
volunteers
should they be invited of course they
should if everybody else is being
invited
and at the end of the day this could
both become unwieldy
a a simple big big thank you from this
council
would be i am sure a big bonus in all
those people's
um hearts and at the end of the day
if this council really wants to support
um organizations out there which do
voluntary work
then let them put their money where
their mouth is and let them
support them through through grants
through funding
to help support these as we go into the
future
and not just put on a one-off thing for
let us say the chosen few
because at the end of the day there'll
be a lot of i'm sure mayors and
deputy mayors and even chairs and
chairmans going through this this event
as well as um very well
um deserving volunteers so
to me i'm quite happy to support one two
and three i'm not so happy to support
him for
i don't think it's necessary i think a
big thank you from this council
and perhaps this council helping to
support those organizations that need or
support now
where money is concerned thank you thank
you councillor hocking i see that
we have three remaining blue hands
members that have already spoken on this
item
counselor gribble
thank you chairman for allowing me to
come back i i just
really wanted to comment on counselor
connor who i have a great respect for
uh and i fully agree with the
recommendations here i just didn't want
the
the sports side of life kick the touch
so i'm sure the executive will look at
the future to reintroduce thank you very
much
okay thank you for that to councillor
mcgregor
thank you chair um just to re-emphasize
that it's not been kicked into touch
and that it did go ahead last year and
it's probably going to go ahead again
this year
perhaps virtually but just just to make
a point
um and this is actually emphasized by
councillor ron pert
is that the sport and community award
mainly
gives to people who are providing
charity work even in the sports sector
see these people are volunteers giving
up their time
to work with disadvantaged children uh
the boxing club was a worthy winner
because
for that very reason really and and
that's a gentleman who's a former world
champion
um who won the title by beating one of
my favorite boxers at the time
um and he won it because of the work he
does in the community so
when we talk about sports and community
being separate we have to bear in mind
that many of these sports
awards go to people who are working in
communities so that is still a
consideration
and it's not been kicked into church so
it's a little bit disappointing that we
keep hearing that
um being mentioned now in terms of the
in terms of the motion i'm fully behind
uh every point on the the motion i would
say however
that within the next 12 months we have
to see and wait
and and see what happens in respect of
coded
because we are no by no means out of the
woods yet and
the prime minister is still talking
about you know a potential third wave
and we are looking at variants
cropping up around the world so we we do
have to provide a little bit of caution
and perhaps in principle back uh the
motion
but wait out to see what's what's
happening before we make a concrete
decision on how we proceed
thank you very much thank you council
linda patrick
um listening thank you chad listening to
the debate
i think one of the issues seems to be
about giving nominations and making it
into an award ceremony
would it not be possible to change that
into a thank you event
which would be um a different thing
altogether
because i really do think that these
sort of thank you events
it's not just about thanking volunteers
it's also about them meeting
networking and sharing good practice
and finding out about various ideas that
have worked for people so there's a lot
more to it
than just a thank you event and but
that's
that's what i would suggest i mean i
don't know if it can be an amendment
or i
i've i've noticed that the next speaker
is councillor russell before i go to
councillor russell
i see that the leader has put his hand
up and i think he might be responding to
your comment
leader uh well thank you thank you
chairman
it's just to draw colleagues attention
to
uh item four in the motion which is
simply
uh to say a thank you event be agreed in
principle
the executive member for homes and
communities with officers
explore how the event could be held how
nominations could be made
and report back to a future council
meeting so i think that deals with
everything
in
a simple thank you event is held
and and council is further consulted on
what that might look like and it deals
with the issues that uh
council linda pedrick has raised cancer
hocking is mentioned
and some of the others as well and i
think it's an entirely appropriate
notion
and i would resist amendment because i
think it picks up the points that be
made
yes thank you for the clarification
leader uh
last but not least councillor sylvia
russell
oh thank you chairman well uh somebody
who's been very much involved with the
sports personality awards really
right from the beginning i think it's
right that it's kept for that and the
community
awards are treated entirely separately
and deserve a separate a separate
recognition
and i would point out that the sports
personality award evening was fully
sponsored
as well and it was greatly looked
forward to by everyone who attended
particularly those who were going to get
awards
and there were video presentations of
their of their achievements
throughout the evening so it was special
in that way
and i hope it could possibly be
restarted again when we get over this
emergency but certainly on the community
side
when i was chairman of the council i did
have some receptions and
invited lots of members to lots of
representatives from the voluntary
sector
we used to hold chairman's lunches at
one time and
uh that was always a nice thing to do
where you you
you not only drew in people from the
community but also
officers and staff as part of the guest
list
to give them a recognition for what they
did for this council
and in the community as well and perhaps
we ought to start to consider
going back to some old courtesies that
we used to be able to enjoy
when you're chairman to be able to
acknowledge what people do
in in a more personal way and using ford
house of course
and the facilities adulthood house uh
which are underused i think these days
thank you thank you councillor russell
so we've we've had a
proposal for the recommendation and a
seconder so can we go to the vote now
please beth
councillor austin
or cancer bradford
do i not get the chance to sum up mr
chairman i thought the
move of the motion normally had a right
of reply at the end of the
debate i don't know i might get older if
you feel the need then please do
thanks i would just like to respond to
some of the points made and some of the
points for far more
relevant than others um and and i i
welcome all the rep
responses i don't know where i got to
with my speech
if the intention is not in any way to be
divisive
or to be excluding it's on the contrary
to be
inclusive and to be as broadly based as
possible
i refrain from giving my
interpretation of what should happen
because that is clearly contained within
item
four we want to explore we want to see
the possibilities we want it to be
um inclusive uh and as
councillor david cox rightly pointed out
it's not a question of
winners and losers we're all winners in
in this context and the and the more we
encourage the better that will be in my
opinion
i could spend the next 20 minutes
talking about what i would like to see
but that is not the role that is not the
role right now
feral i'm perfectly conscious of that
and i really don't want to delay matters
any further
okay i don't want this to be an
expensive event it could be low cost or
no cost
it's it's a way in which parish councils
and
town councils could nominate from their
communities it could be
individual members of this council it
could be members of the public
anybody would be free to nominate in my
opinion and i hope that a wide range of
nominations would come forward and a
wide range of
persons and groups could be celebrated
and thanked thanking people is a good
thing to do
let's let's let's rejoice in that and
and try and move forward together
thank you mr chairman thank you
councillor beth could you resume the
role call please uh councillor austin
or councillor bradford
or councillor bill event org
councillor clarence or cancer colclough
or cancer connet or
cancer david cox or councillor hugh cox
oh cancer doors
can't say dewhurst or cancer evans
or cancer goodman bradbury
or cancer gribble or
cancer haines
jackie hook or cancer jeffrey
cancer jeffries for
cancer keeling four cancer care as well
or cancer mcgregor
or cancer morgan oh
cancer malone oh
cancer natalie yeah cancer the nuttel
four cancer parker calm or
cancer patch cancer pit
council linda pedrec four councillor
phipps
four council persa four
councillor rolison or councillor russell
oh cancer swain four councillor taylor
councillor thorne or councillor wrigley
or cancer parker or
councillor john petherick
thank you so moving on to item eight on
the
agenda recommendation from the executive
future high street fund
the executive member for economy and
jobs to move the recommendation
councilor jeffries
thank you chair um
it's good to hear that there's such a
support today in recognition
of the needs of the younger generation
and the wider community
and what they contribute to the area
cross-collaborative work is key to
fostering a vibrant area i'm sure most
people agree
with me um and that leads me on to
our paper today that i'd like to present
to you
um this paper about this future high
streets fund
seeks full council support today
uh in accepting the future high streets
fund offer
of circa 9.2 million investment the
grant will support
long-held ambitions for newton abbot as
a premier market town
and will enrich the town's offer to
create a vibrant town centre for
everyone
but in particular future generations and
there will be
a presentation now uh from my colleague
um and questions afterwards thank you
chair
thank you
can everyone see my screen okay yes
okay thank you uh thank you chairman and
good morning councillors
uh we've prepared a short presentation
to accompany the recommendation to you
today
which goes into a bit more depth on the
proposals we've submitted to the future
high street fund did
and the background to where they came
from the aim of the future high street
fund is to renew
and reshape town centres and high
streets in the way that drives growth
improves experience and ensures future
sustainability
following a very competitive process
which required us to demonstrate that
the projects were not only
transformational
but also delivered uh were deliverable
and financially viable
the fund also requires any awarded money
to be spent by the end of march 2024
we're awaiting final government approval
which is expected now in early may
and we now need council to confirm the
budget has set out in the recommendation
which has already been provisionally
accounted for in our budgets
and this is to ensure that we provide
the necessary match funding for the
projects
as per our submission
newtown has been a market town for
around 800 years
remaining relevant and adapting to the
needs of its community over that period
the type of market has changed in that
time and the future high street fund
offers the opportunity
for us to deliver the next evolution of
a market town
plans for this evolution of the town
have been developed over the last 10
years or so
so this slide highlights a number of
different studies and plans
developed with input from residents
councillors and key stakeholders over
that time
each element of our bid can be traced
back through this work in some way
as a council we also have a recent
history of investment and regeneration
in the town delivering on the vision and
intervening
where there has been market failure and
we should be under no illusion that if
the council hadn't been making those
investments over time the market wasn't
lying enough to do so
through all of the work a vision has
emerged from albert says devon's premier
market town
well connected accessible and meeting
the needs of the immediate and wider
community
the future high street fund is presented
an opportunity to deliver on that vision
access and fund them to make those
changes
the scope of the fund has been set by
government and the projects chosen were
considered to be the best fit from our
work over the last 10 years
it demonstrates the importance of having
a plan and being ready to respond
there are four key elements to the bid
the markets course in the
top the heart of the town centre a new
cinema
pedestrian improvements along queen
street and improvements to the national
cycle network
i'll give you a brief overview of those
core elements and these are the schemes
that the bid has been assessed on
and the provisional award has been given
for
first at the markets quarter focused on
the market hall and alexandra cinema
building
it'll be a flexible mixed-use space that
improves the town centre offer
both the day time and the evening
economy
the buildings originally designed as a
corn exchange but was split to become a
marker hall in the theater which then
became a cinema
which now has theater use for 2-3 weeks
per year
we monitor footfall into the market hall
on a daily basis and i've seen a
decrease of 35 percent over the last
five years
markets across the country have been
facing the same issues this isn't unique
to newton abbott
and i think there's a consensus that
something needs to be done to hold that
decline and reverse it
to increase footfall both into the
markets and into the town centre
by creating a more flexible space we can
make better use of the building
throughout the day and create a
destination with
much broader appeal attracting more
people into the town
examples we've seen from other towns
have shown that a good market can
increase footfall by 25
this is an artist's impression of how
the alexander cinema building could be
opened up
and flow into the market hall building
while there's food and drink use shown
in the drawing is proposed to create a
flexible space that can accommodate
other users
including performance space more
detailed work on this will be undertaken
once the funding has been secured
and architects have been procured to
look at the more detailed designs
as part of the work uh building up to
this we've looked at other
um examples across the country the
scheme here shown in
ulster and greater manchester has shown
how well this approach can work it's got
a very
similar feel to the market hall newton
albert
um and they've seen an increase in their
footfall by 25
in the seven years between 2010 and
2017.
as part of the submission we undertook
survey work to help develop the bid
this slide sets out some of the key
feedback and confirms the appetite for
change
and the need to broaden the appeal we've
also had constructive discussions with
the friends of the alexander theatre
regarding the flexible performance space
and i've developed a memorandum of
understanding that's been sent to the
friends
and how we'll engage with them on
developing these plans
and obviously you heard from dr ward
earlier that workers and those
discussions are still ongoing
um and will carry on you know once conf
once confirmation has been given um by
members
we're also working with scott cinemas
for a new four screen cinema
in the town we know that there's both
the need and demand for a cinema
capacity in the town
we did look to bring forward a scheme
back in 2018
but we ultimately have to shelve that
because the project wasn't viable
the future high street fund has allowed
us to revisit that plan
this slide sets out some recent feedback
from surveys which looked at the impact
of lockdown on cinema goers
and the wider benefits it has how
cinnamon would have on the community
of notes in all of this so the varied
age groups have missed being able to go
to the cinema
the different demographics will be
coming into our town
the working improvements to the markets
building will see further investment
into a cultural quarter
following from devon county's investment
in the pasmo edwards library building
and the town council's investment in
newton's place
the recycle improvements proposed as
part of the bid
and that's part of a wider network for
the national cycle network
you can see hopefully the different
coloured elements
and the key to the right hand side
showing the existing roots in green
the proposed routes to be funded by the
future high street
fund in purple um
propose future routes in orange and then
existing routes
in yellow so you can see that we don't
yet have a connected network
um and there are a number of routes
coming into the town some completely
segregated for possessions and cyclists
however when you get into the town
itself it requires cyclists to join the
main road
so the intention in the long term is to
to bring all these pieces together
and create a better cycle infrastructure
which in turn can encourage greater
usage
as people feel a lot safer cycling
around newton abbott
the council's committed to sustainable
travel improvements not only due to the
contribution it makes to climate change
agenda
but also to enhance the quality of the
public realm
and give a play give greater priority to
pedestrians and cyclists
by developing improved safer routes we
not only encourage sustainable travel
options but also help with physical
and mental well-being the survey work
undertook before submitting the bid
showed strong support for improvements
and the potential for increased use of
cyclone for town centre users
while cycling isn't a significant mode
of transport for shoppers presently it
does have the potential to be a more
realistic option in the future
and clearly with better infrastructure
in place will encourage more people
to consider that option the improvements
along queen street are to improve the
pedestrian experience
providing why the footpaths this
artist's impression
shows the junction with albany street
and lemon jelly on the corner and shows
the benefits to the visit of having
wider payments
and a more pedestrian friendly public
realm
again there was support for the changes
from our survey work but we do
appreciate we'll need to do a bit more
work on the design
once the funding has been secured and
that will include engagement
would that be helpful to show the change
in nature on queen street over the last
20 years
uh and there's quite a bit of detail in
here um
things to point out is to show the
difference
um obviously it's quite stark at the top
on this harlem of the number of shops
along queen street although
interestingly um there's double the
number of charity shops in the same
period
we've also seen an increase in cafes
hairdressers services and residential
uses
so the nature of the area is changing
this is more likely to
spend time more time in the town
visiting the businesses
and less emphasis on pop and shock
so the next steps will develop more
detailed engagement plans
on on the different aspects of the
proposals the market cinema project
uh is to be delivered between 2021 and
2025 so i mentioned earlier about
funding needs to be spent by end of
march 2024
we can still carry on with projects
where we're not utilizing the future
high street fund for that element after
the end of march 2024 so
some of that funding will be team bridge
funding
the cycle enhancements will be in the
next financial year
led by devon county council with with
support from ourselves and the queen
street enhancement to take a little bit
longer to develop
design the plans uh with implementation
by 2023 2024
so just just as a recap uh what we're
hoping to achieve
from the future high street fund
projects develop newton abbas into
devon's
premier market town to see an increase
in footfall into the town centre
to increase the appeal of the town to a
much wider range of visitors
enhancements to the evening economy
offer and to create a modern more
flexible town centre
uh i'll now hand it over for any
questions
thank you um i think we can probably all
recognize how important
this revitalization of newtonia is to
its future
um and after having looked at the
proposals and hearing from dr ward this
morning there are obviously still
concerns around the alexandria theater
and i would just like some real
reassurance that any proposals that are
developed and
made will be brought before the council
and not just be made under a delegated
decision
and that will be made aware of any
proposals
and and just that people are kept in the
loop basically not just us as
councillors but the public
as well as friends of the association i
know there is some kind of consultation
period but i think it's important
with something this vital that we have a
real open and transparent process
thank you sir i can't so councillor
bulevant
uh thank you i'll keep my comments very
very brief
um because of herder but i think it's
important to remember that newton abbott
itself received his charter to be a
market town in
1220 so it's almost it was exactly 800
years ago
and the investment to change the town to
make it more
of a focused market is obviously very
welcome
and i think it's something that will be
certainly something that
future generations look back on
hopefully as it being a great success
um so i'm delighted that uh the council
is coming forward with his proposals i
think they are
subject to the input of residents and
other people
going to be the right ones for the town
and uh endorse and be happy to propose
or second this motion as it goes forward
thank you
come to the doors hi thank you
uh i've got some concerns actually about
the uh
the optimism for the full screen cinema
i was wondering actually if anyone
uh within the team or within the council
has any experience of running
cinemas uh because i've i've run joint
ventures with picture has cinemas across
the country the
largest independent chain uh or should i
say former largest independent chain of
cinemas they're now owned by cineworld
and the flux and fluidity that has hit
the cinema
industry has not solidified at all
it is in a state of uh
a complete nowhere-ness at the moment
because of streaming
and uh and covid and and the release of
films is not guaranteed
i would forewarn this council uh
that the uh they may well be uh
supporting
the investment in infrastructure uh and
the development of something that
will not have any public utility in the
future conversely
the alex uh cinema which we all refer to
as a cinema
uh the building and uh and that space uh
pre-date cinema
by some hundred years so uh the utility
of that space is not is is actually
without doubt a a public community
performance space
but of course we're not talking about
that at the moment and we we haven't
been involved in any of those
discussions
uh but i yeah it's a word of caution i i
don't know the basis
uh because i don't think the industry
knows the basis
of how cinemas will operate in the near
future
thank you council doors would would neil
will need like to respond to councillor
door's question
uh yes um the
we were in discussions with scott
cinemas uh who are the current
um providers at the alexander cinema um
and they're looking to they'll be the
ones to take over
the the new four screen cinema so uh
it'll be a continuation of
of um what we've got at the moment and
they are still keen they still think
that they'll be the market for it and
a confidence moving forward okay
thank you for that councillor malone
um thank you um i've seen the engagement
survey upon which much of this is
predicated and uh
you know i i have to say i i think a lot
of it is a
slightly nonsensical it's it's um
it's it it's it's worded in such a way
that it's very hard to disagree with it
i mean of course we all want better
disabled access
of course we all want greener high
streets but i don't think most people in
newton now but want to see
what's proposed here unfolding before
their eyes and then
being told that they agreed to it i mean
the survey doesn't have any specific
points in it
it should if it included questions such
as you know do you want
the historic interior of civic landmarks
to be smashed out
yes or no do you want uh your high
streets
planned by people that you buy it by
committees that don't include anyone who
know
really anything about culture you know
questions like
do do you want all the parking in queen
street to be removed
we also press on with plans to double
the size of this town
you know i think the answers to those
questions would have been very
forthright and very clear
um and i think that the survey that was
put to people
should have made these things far more
um
sort of spelled them out far more
clearly to people
thank you councilman uh would either
neil or nina like to respond to
councillor malone's uh questions
sorry i wasn't sure what the question
was thank you
the consultation process and the
accuracy of it why didn't we just ask
people's
straightforward questions about what is
actually on the blueprint
not nebulous questions about do you want
your town to be nice
thank you well the plans um
come from so it's not just one lot of
consultation it wasn't i mean that was
they were the surveys that were done to
inform the submission which links in
with what
the government had set out for the
criteria the plans and ideas have been
generated
for many many years um said in the slide
that
started in 2010 in terms of the
publication but there were
plenty of engagement activities before
that
um looking at how the town's going to
going to change and
with those change some things that exist
now will have to to be different so
um it's the the questions we're trying
to look at
how we introduce the things that we've
been told for many years people want to
see so
increasing sustainable forms of travel
improving the public realm uh but also
looking at how buildings are used and
um you know these these are the there's
opportunity and all the questionnaires
for people to give views
and alternative views and if they
disagree uh and they were all considered
it's looking at
the solutions and ultimately coming back
to the vision
of what we're trying to achieve um i'm
not aware of any survey that goes into
the detail of
and describes things as destruction i
disagree there is destruction um
we're looking at the opportunities
there's the principles have been
established and
further work will be done to develop it
but it'll be done sympathetically i
appreciate uh not everyone's going to
agree with that but
we've we're basing it on the feedback
we've had over
many many years and the questions which
were helped developed by the consultants
who helped us submit the bid
um we're looking to ensure that what we
submitted
was in line and was a strong case
and i think once the plans are further
developed you'll get to see those in
in more detail thank you neil councillor
hawking
uh thank you chairman um like all
surveys and i agree with councilman
like all surveys the questions asked
well we'll give you the
give you the answers that you want from
that survey and that's just what's
happened but this
this these surveys that's happened
certainly over the high street
uh funding bid um
queen street has been brought into that
bid and
because the the council has to take
boxes that the government has set and to
cross the lines that the government have
put there in order to get this money
that
uh team bridge require to to
upgrade or regrade or whatever way you
want to use
the the market hall um
and that is why queen street is in the
bid because if they were to put the bid
in just for market hall
they wouldn't have got it they had to
put it in to show substantial
uh travel and um how they're going to
help pedestrians how they're going to
look at the high street etcetera
etcetera and that's what's queen
street's done but when we first started
talking about
uh looking at queen street they were
going to take away the
the parking which was fair enough um and
put it into
um qriket field that has now not
happened
because again um when you look at what
the government set down
that did not fall and fall in with what
the government required for your for
this funding
so that was took out so now we're left
with something that people don't
really want businesses don't really want
it even though
the surveys that we're being shown
say they do um you only need to talk to
the town center development manager and
she will tell you a completely different
story
um going on to the market hall the first
picture that we were shown today shows
the old
market hall in the center of newton
abbott
looking proud standing there as
a as a building which everybody saw
as the center of the town and went to
now we haven't got that because back in
the 70s
um cambridge district council allowed a
developer to come in
and destroy what was around that
building
and put up what we now know as market
walk
um not the brightest ideas in
in living history when you start looking
back at it but then i suppose hindsight
is a marvelous thing
you're only going to look at the center
of plymouth um where they've had to
rebuild after
after the bombings um again
hindsight is a marvelous thing if we had
we had the chance again we would do
something completely different i am sure
and the same with market walk it is not
it is not ideal it's not made for
purpose
people go there they can't sit because
there's no seating
um several of the shops are still
empty because either the wrong size or
the rent
and that is too expensive um the market
hall itself
um it's not got as many people not got
as many stalls in there
the question why well we're changing the
way we
the way we shop um we're buying stuff
online now
but prior to that we have the influx of
uh
pawn shops and um you've got one in the
one in the time center which does very
well i use it myself
uh and i've got to admit that perhaps
that is one of the reasons why
the market is failing um but i use the
pound shop
you've got one out of king state and
home base or home bargain sorry
um with free parking all the way around
and people travel from miles to go to
that shop
um so we then go to ask yourself
is knocking down a wall between the
market hall
and the alexander theater which let's be
fair um
is not really fit for purpose and we can
all agree with that
to bring it up to the 21st century it
needs money spent on it
but at the end of the day it is a
theater
and if we were to spend a little bit of
money on it and have a right and have
the right
um management organization in managing
it
i am sure that could be a
an income for this council um
without spending without destroying
what's there and i failed to see
how knocking that wall down and bringing
the
market and the market hall and the
alexander
into one large hall i
failed to see how you're going to put on
a christmas pantomime how are you going
to put on
um a musical through the summer
because surely these sort of things you
need a theater
and by knocking down that wall you've
not no not got a theater
you've got a large open building which
is being turned into
a cafe turned into a bar stroke
restaurant
with a with a couple of um
several removable market stalls at one
end
and some purpose-built units at the
other
um i can't see oh this is going to work
and i've failed to see how this will
work
um you we've been told that we is going
to be a
understanding memorandum understanding
with um
the friends of the alexander but what
does that mean
you know there's there's nothing we've
got no no
documentation to say what's in what was
in there and yet we're being asked
to agree to these particular these
budget figures now before we know
exactly what's going to happen
i failed to see and this is my only
personal opinion and
i have been newton abbott all my life
born up in king staton but newton abbott
has been my time
and i have been a newton abbott person
as far as i'm concerned
all my life and i've failed to see how
this will
help newton abbott bounce back from what
from where we are
um newton abbott has got
the problems with newton albert and i
think tinbridge and devon county cancer
can do a lot to help that
we our rents are too high within the
town center
or our rates are too high all right
you'll see that's government
but our rates are too high
you if you want to improve newton abbot
why don't you go and walk through newton
abbott
tomorrow and you smell the the smell the
smell
from the drains and that which were
never laid right from the word go when
devon county council um put in the
through courtney street that is the
areas we should be concentrating on
and making sure that the environment
that we
think asking people to come to is
correct
clean tidy fresh and
make sure that we've got businesses
there that can come and afford
the rents and the business rights that's
being charged to the town center
there's a lot of things we can do
without actually
knocking down a wall and
titivating around uh inside that
building
you'll never ever get that building back
as a pro
building because that has been destroyed
that was destroyed back in the 70s
i wish i could support this as someone
from
newton abbott as someone who wants to
see 9 million
spent in my time i wish i could support
it
but i cannot support it because of the
what the way
that these plans are being put together
and these plans
are going to actually in my view and i
hope i'm wrong
but in my view i think these plans will
do more harm
than good thank you thank you councillor
hawking uh councillor bradford
thank you chair i understand that a lot
of work has been done with specialists
who have vast experience
of development schemes but
anyone who's worked in the theater knows
that the process is as important as the
performance
this is a theater we're talking about a
very old theater
it has a life it's a grade two listed
building
i've looked at the quarter bridges team
not one of them has any background in
the performing arts
that's like asking a baker to make a
brick wall
you have a precious jewel the alexander
theater
it's in your hands and your custodians
for this rare gem in newton abba
where you've got a company who has
no idea of the magic of theater
and they're deciding the future of it
it's an important and historical
building and i believe should not be
entrusted to
anybody with all due respect who does
not have at least
some credentials to understand from a
theatrical point of view
what is at stake here we need the arts
more than ever now
and we can't just allow this to be about
money there's so much more at stake for
this community
what are we trying to achieve please
please do not gut the alexander theatre
you only have to see the facebook page
newton albert nostalgia
to realize that residents want to keep
their beautiful old buildings
on to the multiplex cinema i think we're
10 years behind
we're 10 years too late you've only got
to go up
country those places are empty
thank you thank you councillor branford
councillor kurzweil
you have muted councillor kurzweil
i do beg your pardon i listened with a
lot of concentration to councillor mike
hocking
who obviously knows newton abbott
inside out and upside down
he speaks a lot of sense
the alexandria theater and
i do go there when it's when we're
allowed to to
to see a film i'm always
amazed that unless there's a real
blockbuster film in there
the theater this cinema can be
practically empty i can be one of
10 maybe 12 in the auditorium
and i often wonder how can they afford
to keep it going
it's a wonderful amenity but how can
the um the consultations the people who
are putting all this
together how can they warrant a
multi-multiplex cinema
where there are three four maybe more
screens
when they can't even service two
to keep them full on a regular basis
the joy of the alexander theater is that
it's
a multi-use building as it is because
with the people the actors the
um used to be called the newton abbott
musical comedy society years ago i can't
remember what it's called now
but they use it
as you say pantomimes and other
theatrical work
and the cinema complement each other
i dread to think what will happen
if we lose this and this historical
building
as councillor hawking said is a
wonderful building
it complements the library and other
buildings around and uh i'm
i'm thinking more towards councillor
hawking
than i am to the presentation that we
heard thank you
thank you councillor kurzweil leader of
the council
um thank you chairman well i'd try to
think what that happens to newton abbott
if we don't take the future high street
fund of 9.2 million
and invest in making another devon's
premier market turn
what i've heard of people say we're
concerned about change but i've offered
no vision about what they would do
and where they would draw the money from
people are scaring
members of the public by saying the
alexander as a building is at risk it's
not it's a listed building it's staying
um we're trying here to support
newtonian to invest in
abbott council is right i'm not familiar
with all of the detail of the 1970s
but that would have been either the
decision of 1970s cancers and maybe
teenage cancers possibly
newton other cancers whenever the plans
were started these things don't
happen overnight as
neil blaine is explained there has been
some long process to work through
a number of ideas to actually generate
footfall into the
center of newton both for a cinema
i remember years ago when exeter had two
cinemas
the abc and the odeon and each had
well the abc had one screen then
developed two and the odeon
had several and then the picture has
came and then the view came
and we must have all thought to
ourselves my goodness where are these
audiences
but they found the cinemas and the
cinemas up until recent times we've
covered
have have thrived have they not at least
they've remained open
and as councillor door says with his
experience of pictures
i remember going to the pitch house and
seeing a range of films both modern
blockbusters
and really runs of older films that
we've enjoyed previously and want to go
why can't newton abbott enjoy that why
is it to be condemned to the museum of
history
why can't investment be permitted why
can't we draw on
the wider areas of newton newton albert
has
never ever had the chance to counter
next minutes to start cross
whitstone temper and saint mary and draw
people in from around the area
people talk about the alexandria but
actually it's a cinema
which is used what for three weeks of
the year as a theater
that's the truth of the matter the
building stays is a listed building
owned by the council
we have a once-in-a-lifetime chance to
grab this if councillors don't want the
9.2 million
i think you have to say so now because
actually a lot of work has gone into
this
and the reason the grant was down scaled
by government from
the 13 million we requested was simply
about the demand from
other towns and communities seeking
government support from the future high
street fund
and we got down downsized a few got the
fuller man a small number
most were downsized and we were
downsized to 9.2 million and that's why
the
multi-storey car park or decking at
cricket field was put to one side
members this is in your hands you either
live in the history museum
for newton abbott or we take the
opportunities that we've got and we
invest both
government money and change money
endeavor money
into newton upper and try to make it
devon's premier market
town or you simply say but actually you
don't want to do that
we leave things as they are but the
consequence of that and you know it in
your hearts even if you're not going to
admit it today
is that the footfall will decline the
shops will close
more than they have already because of
covered and now but will not thrive
but just wither on the vine as people
vote with their feet and go somewhere
else
and i say right now right today this is
the moment actually when we need to
stand up
grab that government money and do the
very best we can
because this is it this is the chance to
make devin
uh make newton now that devon's premier
market time i would employ all
councillors
to support the recommendations here and
let's invest
in newton abbott thank you chairman
thank you leader councillor jackie hook
any chair for the chance to speak um i'm
speaking not only as an executive member
but also
current devon county and district
councillor for the town centre area
and it's not often we get the chance to
confirm and approve acceptance of 9.2
million
of government funding to invest in the
future prosperity
of the main town in our district and
that that that
makes me a bit surprised to hear some of
the comments that are coming forward
today
um if this to me represents an
opportunity for newton but to define its
role as the premier town of the areas
serving not only the needs of its own
residents but those of the surrounding
area
and visitors to our district it will
enable businesses to prosper
the environment of our town centre to be
improved and the quality of life for all
residents to be enhanced
and nobody's thanked the officers yet
that have worked on this
um bid but i would like to thank all the
team bridge officers and there are devon
county officers as well
that have worked on this bill and i'd
like to thank them very much
to me it feels like the culmination of a
journey which began
with the vision expressed by people of
newton abbott in the town's community
plan of 2008
and i was actually on that community
plan group
that community plan then provided the
context for the newton abbott
neighborhood plan
which was drawn up in conjunction with
the people of the town
and voted for them voted by them in a
referendum in 2016
following extensive public consultation
and that neighborhood plan
called for the greening of the town
center opening up better cross-town
cycling and walking connections the
addressing of traffic issues in the town
center
including quote the remodeling of
traffic priorities in queen street
and the improvement of the evening
economy all those elements of the town's
vision and priorities for the town
centre
are reflected in the elements of the
future high street proposals
just looking at the queen street um
specifics
the voices of the people of newton
abbott place
um queen street and making queen street
more pedestrian friendly
top of their liches wishes back in 2008
ambitious plans were drawn up then for
queen street to make it more pedestrian
friendly
but we have struggled since then to
achieve the funding
and that is why this represents such a
fantastic opportunity
to finally set queen street shops
traders restaurants and cafes
on a path to increased financial
sustainability
by improving the street and lessening
the impact of motor vehicles
we will create a street where people
want to linger
browse and spend money they won't have
to continually step into the road to
avoid others
and they won't have to breathe in the
fumes of queuing cars on a saturday
afternoon
we need to remember cars don't spend
money and neither do people sat in cars
people spend money when they're out of
their cars in a present environment
that they want to spend time in and this
is what future high street funding will
enable us to do
in terms of car park capacity um
unfortunately at the moment
newton has quite a lot of car park
capacity um i'm not i'm talking
pre-covered of course
and we do have spare car parking
capacity wouldn't it be wonderful if we
didn't because that might show a more
prosperous economy so this is what we're
aiming to get to
at some point we may need a qriket
filled decking we don't at the moment
with regards to alexandria theater these
proposals um i'm surprised that people
think they've come out of the blue these
proposals have been consulted on
and been available for people to see in
terms of
the plans for the regeneration of the
town centre for at least the last three
years
um more high profile since we've been
discussing the future high streets bid
they were consulted on last summer and
in fact last july executive considered
the public consultation responses
um to the bid um and at that executive
meeting i was there i
i don't remember any other councillors
attending i don't think they did
certainly no other councillors raised
any concerns as a result of the public
consultation responses
or or offered any um points on the path
we were on with regards to the bid
um and as we know as we've been told the
detail regarding the theater's future
use with regards to performances
is currently being discussed with all
stakeholders
to me the future high street proposals
are exciting
and aimed at enhancing the offer of the
town to encourage football
and help all traders in the town centre
um
if we're talking about these the group
that's meeting with the
theater representatives i mean i'm not
on that group and i'm the county and
district councillor for the town centre
i'm happy to trust our leader and
councillor nina jeffries to take those
um discussions forward and as i
understand it
nina has um a history in the arts and
entertainment sector
as far as i know um so
um i i'm happy to trust um then to take
full of those discussions um
so to me we can proceed confident that
we have the majority support of the
town's residents
and confident that this district council
is delivering on those wishes
it is important that we continue to
consult on the fine detail of the
proposals to ensure we achieve the best
outcome not only for residents not only
for current residents businesses and
visitors
but those of the future and that's what
enforces important
we must continue to listen and seek to
allow for differences of opinion
about the detail of the way forward but
without losing the overall
transformational vision
that is behind these well thought out
interlinked proposals
and i'm sure this is the desirable
stakeholders
so i have no hesitation in welcoming and
supporting the 9.2 million funding
for our town and the proposals as
outlined in the report
thank you thank you councillor come to
the doors
thank you i just wanted to come back on
a couple of points because some very
important uh things were raised uh when
when councillor jackie hook just
mentioned the plans for the alex were
were circulated and no one fed back uh
that's not true i asked for the
the report the consultant's report that
was done over uh
i had it over a year ago i did feedback
to the leader that i didn't think
uh the the plan uh held any substance i
couldn't find out who wrote it what
qualification they had
and i believe the company that wrote it
don't exist anymore i i would
proffer that i know more about the uh
the
the the business model than the people
who wrote that plan
um when council iconic said cinemas
thrived in exeter i i've reframed that
cinema
has hung on by its fingertips uh
hence uh independent cinema has been
brought up by the larger
uh groups so uh picture house was bought
by cineworld which was then bought by
another conglomerate is the largest
uh cinema group in the world and they
are all
uh waiting to find out what happens
after covid which is why
why the the idea of the full
screen cinema is the one that just
stands out as being so i know scott
cinemas are optimistic about it
because what else can they be um
the uh counselor hockey made some some
some very very good points as did cancer
kurzweil
the model of operating cinemas is they
run a
10 20 capacity uh they make their money
on selling suites to people
you know it's a very very fine margin
and how many people here
subscribe to streaming services in the
last year that they didn't have
because all the studios are going to be
putting their their releases
live on streaming services there will be
a sea change in the
cinema industry so what we do want
is to regenerate uh the city center the
town centre we'd like 9.2 million pounds
we'd like it to be sent spent on a
sustainable plan
a sustainable plan that reflects the
needs of
the residents and then we go back to
uh the great who listed building uh one
of my venues
is in a great two listed building as
well and that protects the front of the
building not the inside
uh and the plans we're not debating
today but the plans were put forward
to take out the center of the alex the
inside of the alex the heart of the alex
uh theater can we call it a theater uh
that have been there
well in excess of the time uh double the
time that cinema has been operating that
that is the
the area we need we need to focus on so
much as i applaud the
the uh optimism the ambition
the endeavors of the officers uh i think
we need to have a realism that we were
working in a very
very different time a very fluid time uh
and we need to change this plan
we we need it to be sustainable uh and
and one of those key points
that people are excited about and
emotional about
is the ripping out of the heart of the
alex theatre thank you councillor doors
councillor malone
uh thank you thank you um yeah
um councillor capone said uh if
councillors feel that we shouldn't
accept this 99.2 million then we
we should say so um okay i'll uh
i'll take that bait uh if if it's a
choice between this plan
and not taking the money then i would
say let's not take the money
um we need to get away from the idea
that spending money always makes things
better
um this council and i'm not talking
about this council i'm talking about
going back 50 60 years but tim bridge
council has a history
of spending vast sums of money making
newton abbott worse and worse
and worse uh now
our duties as councillors i think are
the same as the first duties of doctors
first do no harm this plan is the
civic equivalent of botched plastic
surgery i don't
i don't think it's money that should be
spent now i agree with councillor
hocking more than i've ever agreed with
anyone on this
council including possibly myself um
he was right that the demolition of the
market walk
uh did a lot to rip out the heart of
this town
and what remains of that heart i think
this
is dealing a death blow to i mean
there's there's nothing in this plan
that puts
light or laughter or music or culture
into this town and that is what is going
to give it a sense of place
a sense of civic pride and a sense of
itself
there is nothing in this plan that adds
any of that
it just adds ideas about oh people can
congregate people can do this
i i have never had to step off the
street pavement
of queen street into the road whilst
perusing the charity shops which are the
only businesses that can really operate
there
they don't they don't need double-sized
pavements
to let people into charity shops they
need a relief on their business rent
that will allow
you know entrepreneurs to take a pun on
on on taking
rented premises they need things like
that they need real things
they don't need big pavements
and it just doesn't work frankly and
you can't just keep saying that the
public are behind this
i don't believe you i don't believe the
public are behind this
thank you thank you councillor milan
councillor russell
russell thank you chairman um first of
all i'd just like to comment
uh mike on his passionate
support and uh standing up for newton
abbott and
the way he does he always he always
speaks very well and
well done mike but i would like to just
say that had team bridge not
taking back the ownership of market walk
and the income that was that it brings
in we wouldn't be able to be having this
discussion today
if you remember market walk was owned by
some
london insurance set up and all the
rents and every and the
advantages of that just flowed into into
london
areas where they didn't give to toppings
about what happened
in newton abbott but we do have control
now
and this is where we are today by uh
looking
further what we can do there um market
walk has always been the principal area
and it's always it will always be a
focal point i don't doubt
but i've got every confidence in the
future of newton abbott
and the plans that are there i look
forward to the improvements that will
come about
sadly we don't have the market as we
used to do and every wednesday you would
come into newton of it
to see the livestock and have a drink at
the globe
and and the farmers would congregate
those days sadly very sadly have gone
but i i don't think we need to lose the
spirit of newton abbott
by improving the center and encouraging
people to keep coming in
for what's on offering newton abbott and
um i have every confidence in the future
of newton abbott
and the effect that it will have on the
surrounding towns as well it will be our
magnet it always has been
but it will also bring prosperity to to
the
to the towns surrounding newton abbott
so i have every confidence thank you
gentlemen
uh thank you councillor russell
councillor hawking
yeah thank you jared for letting me come
back um just very quickly
um i'd just like to um say that cancer
conic played a nice
a nice trump card there when he said
that um
if we don't want this 9 million pound to
come into newton average we should say
so now
nobody in their right mind will will say
that
and council comic knows that we all need
this money to come into the town center
this money could be spent
it could be spent three or four times in
um
in things that will improve the town
center
but what we're talking about um the
problem i have
is that this money is coming with a plan
that i do not believe uh will will
benefit the town center
yes we could all say yes we need we need
uh wider payments in
in queen street um because there is
pinch points
a lot of that's down to companies
putting
a boards out and making making the
payments
narrower which is against the law but no
one seems to do anything about it
so yes we're going to um we're going to
increase the size of the
of the payments i've got no objection to
that
but what i have got objections to is is
the
way that we're going to use the other
bit of money and
that is the problem um they say there's
going to be consultations
but the problem is that the plan is
already there the plan is in
whatever it may be tweeted a little bit
but the plan is there
now how do we as
counselors and i'm talking for myself
how do i
protect what is now the heart of newton
abba
how do i protect that um
but also accept the fact that i'm gonna
have to
allow that heart to be destroyed to
accept this money
i am falling on the side of council
malone
to say if it relies on if this money
relies on us
damaging and in my view it will damage
the harder newt never
then i say i don't want it um and i know
exactly what cancer
connect will say well you know it will
die anyway
newton albert will not die newton abbott
is still the best
one of the best towns in the area we
have
lease shops empty than anywhere um
we could have no shops empty if only we
made sure
that the rents were being were at a
reasonable level so that people could
come in and start up businesses
um that was the idea of the market in
the first place people would go to the
market and start a business up
and then move out into into a shop and
and progress that way
we have to look at this in a different
way
and just throw in money at the center at
the market hall by knocking down this
guy and making it a lot bigger by
knocking down two retail shops which we
have now and putting up a full screen
that cinnamon was never going to be
there we talked about putting that
cinema under the multi-story car park
at one point um but that was poo pooed
again
i can understand there was height issues
and whatever you
but do we really want maltese do we
really want the multi-story car
um the multiplex cinema right in the
heart of our main shopping area
or do we want that in where our cattle
market is now
um because we know very well that the
sale of cattle
and sheep and that doesn't happen there
or if it does it's
very very infrequent there is so much
that could be done to newt nava if only
we started thinking outside this box
instead of actually putting everything
into one
one problem which is the market hall
because that will bring in an income and
i'm sorry to say but that will bring an
income in
to tdc or at least they think it will
bring an income into tdc
if they turn it into a a restaurant
bar where they can have a bit of
entertainment we saw a picture
of a place up the country where they
where they've done it
i have lived in now that long enough to
know that i'm not sure whether newt now
but we'll
we'll accept that we only got to go
around and see what's happened the pubs
are shut
there's several pubs are sure we've lost
two or three cinemas that we have i
think we had four at one point
um perhaps just before i was uh i was
born but we did have four i think
we've no loss we've already got the one
and
you know i i'm sorry i i sure i could go
on forever i'm very i'm very
disappointed in the fact that we're
doing something yet again
that i do not think newt never will
benefit from
uh and i shall i shall vote against it
even though
i know i shouldn't because the money
needs to come into the town
but on a principle i will look at it
thank you councillor hawking councillor
bradford
thank you chair for letting me come back
again um
i'd just like to clarify that
i too have lived in newton abbott all of
my life i agree with council
councillor hawking wholeheartedly um
of course i want to say yes to 9.2
million
but i can't sign it off with this these
plans
and getting rid of the only bit of
culture we have in newton-other
i feel that the alex's fate is sealed
and going back to um
the friends of the alexandria the new
the newton
amateur dramatic society that they are
only allowed to do three weeks
they'd love to do more than three weeks
the residents don't want this they
really don't
and i couldn't possibly vote for it
thank you
thank you councillor branford councillor
gordon hook
thanks chair i really didn't intend to
to speak on this
issue um many will be rejoicing at that
but i'm afraid i'm gonna let them down
um we've heard a lot this morning
good bad and indifferent um
i i i wonder what people are actually
thinking about
we are being offered a huge sum of money
9.2 million and people are actually
going to vote against
that gift what planet are you on
this is this is an opportunity a unique
opportunity
it's a one-off to to obtain
external money to hopefully and
that that contains a lot doesn't it the
word hopefully
improve our tone because it is our time
it's my turn it's your turn and it's the
district's
men in town
i've only spoken to two can this is a
confession i've only spoken to two
um business owners in in queen street
neither of whom were aware of these
plans now
i don't know who's that fault that is or
whether that's
something that can be corrected um but
when i explained
a little more about what was due what
was proposed that
they were very enthusiastic they said
that sounds that sounds great that that
really sounds
uh optimistic i hope it happens and of
course we fall into two camps as human
beings we're either optimists or we're
pessimists
i am i recently well i say recently
before cb visited uh where i used to
live in in lewes in east sussex
a town not just similar to to newcastle
is the
administrative center of the district
there and it's the market town or was
the market town of the area
um and it has been in my absence
20 30 years transformed
from how do i put it
old retail to a completely different
vision of a town there were there were
more cafes restaurants
entertainment units than i've ever seen
anywhere
married to a thriving retail
traffic had been reduced and people were
walking freely and comfortably
in clear fresh air now
that is a vision which i didn't have
when i left that town
as i say 30 years or so ago
but it is a vision of the future and we
either we either hang on to what is
the past or we we we are brave and we
we we grasped the opportunity of the
future
with with with real high street
investment that had happened in lewis
it can happen in youth numbers we want
regeneration we need
regeneration i am told reliably that
footfall is declining year on year
in in you know but because the town
just isn't moving with the times now i'm
not saying what the times are what they
should be that's for future consultation
and future debate and and so on and so
forth
but i urge members right now
to grasp this opportunity a large sum of
money
coming the way of real regeneration
the rebirth of newton abbott that is
today
rebirth or continued decline
the choice is yours vote for or against
but to decline 90 million
thank you councillor hook councillor
yeah thank you chairman um well i've
listened very
carefully to all this and certainly i'm
all for regeneration of newton abbott
and 9.2 million
is a lot towards that i go along with
all of that
the only thing that worries me about all
of this
is the future of the alexander
cinema um i come from buxton and
derbyshire
where they have a building exactly like
this
called the buxton opera house this was a
cinema
which was converted into a theater
and opera house when when it was
necessary
it has been most successful and has
done buxton very proud with bringing
people in
to concerts and shows that it uh
puts forward all the year round it has
brought brought money uh
a lot of money into buxton so
what i can't understand is why can't we
keep the alexander theater as it is
and turn it into a performance space of
this nature
where we could put shows on all the year
round that would bring people into the
town
uh to to go to these concerts and shows
that we could put on there
i'm sure there must be a better future
for
the alexander theatre cinema than the
one that we're putting forward so
it makes me very difficult to support
this
because of simply because of the future
of that cinema
thank you thank you councillor
come to the patch
thank you chairman um yes i'm gonna echo
um the contribution of councillor col
colcloth um
myself and my partner often take trips
when we're allowed into actually to go
to the theater
and it's a real shame that we don't have
that facility
um in newton albert and i i do um
i'm glad the point was made that um as i
understand it the reason that the
the alexander theatre was only used as a
theater for two or three weeks a year
was because that was all they're allowed
to use it for
and i think that there are positive um
sort of role models in terms of
the facility council cold cloth is just
mentioned but also
facilities such as the phoenix in exeter
um but it seemed having listened to some
very sort of um strong arguments on both
sides it seems
we're being presented with an impossible
situation as councillors in terms of a
vote between
rejecting 9.2 million um which would go
into the town of newton abbott
or or being faced with um sort of
vandalizing
the um the centre of newton abbott and
and severely compromising the future of
arts and culture in the town
i just wonder if there's scope within um
the recommendations
to add a um an amendment in there that
um this is all accepted
subject to make retaining that building
rather retaining the wall which is being
proposed is um pulled down
and ensuring the integrity of the
theater as a building
um is there any way that we could do
that and and create
some kind of consensus amongst ourselves
go to the jeffries are you able to
respond to that
could you repeat the main part of the
question because that was quite a long
preamble there thank you yeah sure i'm
just wondering if we were to incorporate
an amendment
into the um recommended proposal that we
retained
the war that is currently proposed to be
demolished and
and retain the integrity of of the
theater as a performance space
um than if we would gain agreement
and be able to accept the money but
satisfy the concerns
and i'm hearing about the cultural
future of newton abbott
okay thank you i don't think we're at a
point where we can
make any amendments today because we're
still in discussion
with the theater group about the theater
around the memorandum so that is
something that will
need to be ongoing um
today we need to look at the main point
which is whether or not we want to
accept the 9.2 million
okay well as as i've said i i think the
two are
opposed to each other and andy as i
understand it the um alexander the
theater group that they wish very
strongly
as a central point to retain that war
so cancer patch has suggested an
amendment is is there
then you would like to second cancel the
patch's amendment
yes i i would like to second that i
think that would solve
all the problems if we could get the 9.2
million
and leave the alexander theater alone
then i'd be very happy with it
of course for the future of newton
abbott as well
so i went happy to second that to men
understood so we'll just listen to
the rest of the comments from other
councillors and then we'll go to the
vote so
council sarah parker khan
i think before i say anything i think um
neil blaney was looking to
make comment there oh right yeah sorry
chair
um because i've been made co-host a
competitor blue handoff
um the the bid that we've submitted
um the plans have been drawn up but
obviously there's still more detail
to be done um we cannot give the
guarantee
about retaining the wall or not it's
something we've discussed
with the group but the the use of that
build and the flexible
use of that building and what income
generation
can come from that is an important part
of the viability
of the project now we did look at all
options and the consultants that
assisted us
in developing them i know there was
reference um
to quarter bridge but they were
supported by a company called group
ginger who do have a history
of dealing with the arts as well and
when
developing the scheme and the project
i've submitted a lot of the points that
are being raised
were considered in that work and
ultimately
we put forward a scheme that was viable
delivered on the objectives but also
complied with the government's criteria
of the submission
so fully take on board the point we will
be looking at
the design uh and the issue of the wall
is something we've
we've discussed with the group um once
the money is being confirmed
we get the architects in to help us uh
and we're working with the group that's
one of the things that will be looked at
but we can't make that a a caveat of the
decision to say that will definitely
happen
i can't give you that guarantee as it
stands obviously the proposal is to
remove it
we know that the request is in there to
keep it
and look at how that space might be
utilized moving forward
um but it's uh you know members want to
be clear that
if we try and make that commitment we
can't give you that commitment and so i
appreciate the sentiment and why
it's been sought and that is something
that will form part of the discussions
as we move forward and look at how that
all works together
um but as submissive and and and how
we've
put forward and how the governments have
assessed it it's based on what we've put
in
going to the patch so bearing that in
mind are you prepared now to withdraw
your amendment
um just uh before doing that yeah i just
wondered um
listening to that i'm wondering if
there's a solution in terms of
um retaining the option at a future
council meeting of voting on the
retention
of that wall or not to leave the bid
on the table and be able to accept the
money but with that as as a future
decision to be taken
um also i'm not close to the
the contractual issues around this um
but it just seems to me that if it's
possible to remove that stumbling block
for a lot of members and accept the
money then we should look at
any possible ways of doing that
neil are you able to comment on that
please sorry to put you on the spot
um i i think that the the risk
is if we start trying to change the
submission now
and the bid now you know we've got the
offer
on the basis of what we've submitted
we've built the business case
on the proposals and said considering
all of the options uh and looking not
only at what's
um viable but also transformational and
i appreciate there is different views
on on what's been proposed uh and
whether people like it or not
um but i think it's um you
put a bit of significant risk we've got
the proposal
are set out and we're seeking full
council's approval of the budget
details of the design will come through
different committees
i wouldn't expect design detail to come
through to a full council decision
um so i appreciate there's something
there that i guess
counselors who want reassurance on how
we take on board
and discuss those issues and how we take
them forward
and so the decision today is about
acceptance funding um we've got the fund
and the bid is the bid
it has submitted there are things that
we can look at
through the detailed design stage but
it's been appraised on what we've
submitted
um you know it's against the government
criteria uh and so
you know it's it's making the decision
based on what's before you
today um but clearly we'll as a result
of of the conversations
and they'll be part of of what we're
looking at and certain guarantee they
are the discussions around the wall are
part of what we're looking at anyway um
but we did look at
the scheme previously when when we're
looking at the i mentioned in the
presentation
the cinema proposals that we looked at
back in 2018
um which ultimately failed because of
the viability
issues and what could be generated from
the use of the alexander theater
building
or cinema building and um you know how
that might
work moving forward ultimately the
viability
didn't work and it doesn't work for the
project that's submitted we've had we've
looked at
what we've put forward uh in line with
consultants who help us understand
how this is all going to work so i think
you know
we can we can say um for council patches
points
you know they are part of the ongoing
conversations they will form part of the
plans and discussions
once the consultants have been appointed
to develop the plans further
um but the the recommendation is uh
solely about securing the fund and
agreeing
the council's contribution um the match
funding
uh to give government reassurance on our
submission
so councillor patch are you comfortable
with that response and if so are you
happy to withdraw your amendment
uh just one final question to obviously
we're getting to an understanding of the
situation here
but um i'd just like to ask if
there is actually um the possibility and
the scope
within the um sort of um the funding bid
and acceptance of the money
is there the opportunity that that war
can be retained and we
we've been told that they're part of
ongoing considerations
can it actually be retained at wall um
and i still
receive the money
um well in terms of i mean the funding
isn't predicated on that wall
stay in or go and the fundamentals
predicates on on what we've submitted
and we've we've set out the the uses and
how the building be integrated and how
they'll be changed
uh and you know that's part of the
overall offer
um what we said with with the friends
and what we're saying now is uh you know
we we will look at the wall option as
part of design detail design work
and that was something that we discussed
with the group um you know
as as submitted we feel that that's
obviously the best option moving forward
considering all
all things um but that is part of the
conversation then all i can say is that
will be part of the detailed design
work considerations with the architects
once appointed
so counselor perhaps uh there are six
other members wishing to speak now and
more maybe so
so based on what you've just heard are
you happy you know to withdraw your
amendment that will give us
clarification
uh based on what i've heard that it
would it would be possible to retain the
wall
i would like to keep my amendment thank
you chair
okay thank you for that councillor
mcgregor
sorry chair i think i was next but then
you'll go first
oh okay sorry just and mine's just
just a quick question and it's my own
ignorance really and i don't know if if
neil or perhaps
other councillors with more experience
in this sector like councillor doors or
bradford
or malone might be able to help i'm just
looking at the proposals and it talks
about
theater use and event space and i'm
assuming that for that
things like live music and comedy and
performance etc
is i i don't know about acoustics and
all those types of things is there
any reason why a larger multi-use space
won't work for theater like that um
as part of the regeneration as opposed
to what's existing i
i just don't know the reasons why
wouldn't be as good as what we've got
already
i don't know if anyone's able to answer
that at all
um if if i may um i mean
dawes knows more about running theaters
than
than any of us and i'm sure he can give
a far more detailed answer but
for for culture to work in a performing
arts to work in in any kind of space
then it needs to be given respect
basically it needs to be given
it needs to be the main thing that's
going on in that space and people need
to be in that space
for that reason and buying drinks and
talking and chatting or
looking at cheese buying
secondhand dvds but that needs to be
very much
not happening at the same time as a as a
performance a
performance it has to you know it has to
have lights for performance it has to
have the acoustics for a performance it
has to have the uh
emergency exits made for performance
everybody needs to be looking
the right way it needs to be um you know
it needs to be treated as a performance
space
this isn't a performance space it's a
retail space and we're saying well we
could chuck something so
some guy with a mandolin might sit in a
corner or read a poet
read a poem that's that's how i i'm
seeing this plan
it's not made for performance it's made
for that could happen
if we wanted it to but it it it's not as
far as i can see at
a space that is going to be sympathetic
to that happening can i please follow on
with that
what i prefer to do counselor doors
there's a number of people are actually
asking want to ask questions
and i know that you had your hand up and
you dropped it down again now
but you can certainly respond to cancer
parker khan's question
but i would prefer to do it in the
sequence as they appear because i know
that councillor mcgregor has been
waiting for some considerable time so i
will come to your counselor doors
councillor mcgregor thank you chair
um in terms of the elites building uh
there's a lot of hyperbole around
destroying this and
you know and and removing that and it's
it's important to remain the building
was built as a cordon exchange
it's built in exactly the same design
internally as the rest of the market
hall
the wall was put in to separate that
part of it from the rest of the market
hall as a corn exchange
in the 1970s clearly there was a
room for a cinema to go in so scott
cinemas have been there since the 1970s
they they've been running a cinema there
so the theater has been
used very very um
minimally in in real terms for quite a
considerable period of time
so what we're suggesting here is that
as part of the 9.2 million pound
investment in newton abbot
that we make some small changes and
removing one wall
extending the space but still having
creativity
going on in that location is quite
important and we recognize that
and it really comes down to um you know
and i take councillor hawking's points
about
you know he's been in newton about a
long time but he'll have noticed that
over the
the lifetime that he's lived in newton
that he is not the same place
and what we're suggesting you know in
future is
that we're going to force people either
to go out of newton abbott
to go to uh theaters either in timbuth
or
further afield more likely into exeter
um
rather than being able to access
facilities cinemas etc
um and you know if we if we get more
people coming into the town center
then perhaps we can stop the gentle um
erode erosion of our pub scene as well
where we're losing
some really pleasant little places to go
for a for a drink and
and little places that we go for a meal
so what we're trying to do is retain
the attractiveness of newton abbott the
9.2 million pounds is predicated on
not just you know um
doing the alex theater is it's supposed
to be innovative it's supposed to be
ambitious we're trying to reduce the
amount of
car traffic to improve the air quality
something that
many of the counselors that have spoken
to today are really really passionate
about
so the the point comes down to the plans
aren't necessarily going to please
everyone but at the end of the day
it comes down to the balance do we want
the 9.2 million pounds
is there going to be one or two people
who aren't going to be happy
possibly possibly not we don't know but
the situation is
progress is being made with the friends
of the alexander theatre
uh in terms of memorandum of
understanding and
i think that's the main way forward is
direct
uh negotiation between the friends and
then
getting that investment in and getting
the town centre improved and i think
it's really important
and i say that as a you know person has
come down from
some some towns that have deteriorated
for lack of investment in the town
center
so you know my advice would be that we
we we back
the changes and we perhaps can look at
the fine-tuning as
neil blaney has mentioned the officer um
as we go through the consultation period
to put in the final touches
thank you thank you councillor dawes if
you if you
mentioned your point that also could you
respond to councillor parker khan's
question as well please
yes yeah no it they it does both of
those things actually yeah
so in terms of uh council market card's
question the more you try to do in a
space
the more you compromise what you're
doing in that space and
and i think i was going to mention
reference what counselor colclough said
about the
opera house in buxton which is a
stunning performance space
uh she mentioned it used to be a cinema
it did but before that it was a theater
and it was built by frank machamp
and i hope people in newton abbot know
who frank macham is because he's he's
uh in terms of culture he is the guy who
came up with the blueprint of what
the best practice design theater is so
the king's theater in
glasgow and of course the london
palladium
uh and the proscenium arch theater that
frank machamp designed
are the theaters that we all know and
love and they are not
market halls that sometimes have events
on they are theaters that are focused
on the show on the ability to host the
show and and the ability of the audience
to see that show so
so i would again rail back to say
there's a format there that there's a
there's something that works talk to
people who've been using it
for years and i know they haven't been
using it a lot because it's a commercial
business that operates and they've
taken any chance that they can get in
there but given the
the prolific nature of the buxton opera
house since it
re turned from being in a cinema to
being one of the
the premier touring venues in the
country then
then look at look at that as a model
cinemas can turn very successfully into
performance spaces in fact i run one in
bath myself
thank you council of doubles councillor
boulevard
uh thank you chad um as you
will know we we have a an oversight and
scrutiny committee looking at the
cultural
area of newton abbott and that committee
has members from devon county council
the district council and representatives
from the town council as well
as part of the work that that council
has been doing it's been looking at the
provision
of spaces within newton abbott
one of the things that we haven't
addressed or we haven't identified is
that
within walking distance of the alex
there are two
new theaters modern theaters
built for um theater use
they're both within walking distance of
the alex there's the
bushel theater and the daphne coleman
auditorium
both taking more than 200 people into
their auditorium
in terms of their suitability if um
the tour based symphony orchestra is
ending they go by they put on
performances
at the bushel theater at newton abbott
so it isn't as though newton abbot would
lose its ability to put on shows
it wouldn't lose theaters it has these
two performing spaces that are built
purpose-built modern facilities
accessible
and available what we're talking about
and seeking to talk about today
is the investment in newton abbott an
investment in
our belief that newton abbott is a town
for the future
it's a investment in terms of delivering
for the future generations of newton
everest those things that we know or
believe
would improve and enhance newtonis
i think we've spent a hell of a lot of
time this morning going through why we
shouldn't do anything the alex theater
in actual fact what we should be
focusing on is
protecting what we can but investment in
the future of the town
and putting our backing behind what is
proposed
which gives us the ability to make that
difference to deliver those improvements
that we know that the town needs
is what we should in fact be focusing on
so as i say when it comes to a vote
we should remember we're not killing
performance within us now but we're not
killing
the ability to put on shows
we're not there are facilities here that
are available for other people to invest
in each of that so which to put on
any performance as they they want
so please let's think about the future
let's invest in
mute now but the way that is proposed
and make this thing happen
go to the cops
thank you mr chairman to try and be
helpful to uh council match if he was to
change his um
amendment to best endeavors or that the
council notes
the want to retain the wall that
wouldn't preclude the officers
if they have to take it down taking it
down but would make it clear that
it would there was a there's a desire
for it to be retained
i think councillor patch is quite firm
actually about his amendment
i'm just offering it offering advice and
obviously i've been involved with the
tin moth arts quarter we have uh the the
tag center
we have um the cinema uh sorry the old
ice house were all
both the target and the old cinema were
so the old ice house were
uh um properties used for um uh
owned by team bridge they've been used
by arts charities
we have laura wall famous uh illustrator
and artist moved in there
and and it works for us you know and
that's been a a combination of team
bridge facilitating
working and i don't think you never
could afford to give up frankly nine
nine million pounds in the current
climate of investment and i
think it would be terrible if they did
but that's up to you never
thank you we have three more blue hands
and hopefully then we can
once we've heard the comments on those
members we can go to the vote
councillor colclough
yes thank you chairman i seconded
councillor
patcher's amendment because i am
concerned about the future of
the alexander cinema cinema i'm
all for having the nine 9.2 million
i think it's absolutely essential for
newton but
to move forward you know i like to look
ahead and not back
and and it certainly needs some money
spending on it
but i'm very confused on how to vote
because i can't vote for that entirely
when i'm
i'm concerned about the future of the
alexander
cinema so i would like to know that
if i vote for the 9.2 million to go
ahead
with the future of newton abbott that in
the future
beyond when the agreement has been made
the future of the alexander theater can
be discussed again
and the possibility of retaining it as
it
is as a as a performance space and a
theater
with the wall can be discussed at a
future date that a decision can be made
to alter what has been proposed now that
the opportunity is there
to to come back to uh what this
amendment is suggesting
so at this moment i'm seconding
councillor
patcher's uh amendment because i want to
know the answer to that question
councilor clock off my understanding is
that councillor patch is
is quite happy for us to to go for the
9.2 million
but he feels that the condition it
should be conditional on the
alexander theater staying more or less
as it is and the war between that and
being retained um i mean if that is
approved by members and that's what will
happen
but if that doesn't if that isn't
approved then we will vote on the nine
point two million without conditions
i don't see that we can
answer the kill are you still there
yes i'm still here chairman yes i i i
i hear what you're saying chairman and
that amendment would be so
absolutely fine for me okay i'm just
concerned that
if we go for the nine 9.2 million
without the amendment
then we've lost the alexander uh cinema
as it is now and uh and the future of it
thank you councillor kokolov council
bradford
thank you chair for letting me come back
unlike what counselor mcgregor said
it is not small changes to be made to
the alexandra
the alexandra has a proscenium arch
stage it has a large lighting rig
it has an orchestra pit and
lots of changing rooms if you have
another eatery with a space for
something
it'll be a guy with a guitar at the most
at the moment we can put on
full full-scale shows
frank machin who counselor doors
mentioned
it was discovered the other day that he
was actually born in newton about
moving to torquay when he was still a
baby
but we our theatre
is a huge part of newton albert's
history
councillor boulevant mentioned the
bushel theater and the daphne coleman
hall
and we do have two other spaces which
are in walking distance from the theater
but they're teaching theaters they're
nothing like the alexandra
they're not public spaces they're used
by schools
they don't have a proscenium art stage
they don't have an orchestra pit there's
a vast difference
we should be saving the alexandra as it
is
spend some money on that thank you
councillor bradford
two more members to speak now and then
hopefully we can go to the vote
make a decision and then perhaps have a
comfort break
councilor parker thank you chairman
um find myself in a very very difficult
position here
because like um counselor hockey and i'm
a long-term new nabot resident
um i have a great deal of experience of
the town center and the things that go
on in the current state of the town
um i'm very very wary that we have an
offer of 9.2 million pounds here on
offer
and if we do not accept that offer i
think we are
taking a backward step one of the most
foremost uh shows in theater in
my memory is a show called the good old
days
and i think unfortunately if we were to
turn down this offer
we would go to the bad old days and i do
think we do
have to balancing everything up i know
it's a very very difficult situation
um and trust to the fact of discussion
regarding the
actual finalization of the plans for the
alex
because let's face it that's the main
objective we're talking about here
i think we have to balance that fact and
i think we really have to vote
to accept this 9.2 million i understand
what council bulletin said and i
find myself uh not always agreeing with
the council of oliver but in this case
there are other theaters
i know cancer bradford says they're um
uh teaching theaters
but they can be used and there are other
performance areas as well
but it doesn't mean to say that the alex
can't be used as a performance area
totally respect cancer doors and council
malone's opinions about
the theater they they're the experts on
that but we have to balance
this and i do think alex is always very
difficult very difficult for me to be a
new navic counsellor
but i think we have to to accept that
9.2 million and if we don't i think
we'll
in a way cutting our own throat so i
would be in support of it
thank you councillor parker so we are
very very close to going to the vote now
so
counselor doors if you would like to
have the last word please
yes i'd uh i'd be delighted to thank you
uh i like the mention of the good old
days because uh
my uh plymouth-born mother-in-law uh did
feature in the good old days in fact i
see her over my shoulder there on the
board
uh but the um the thing i actually
wanted to
to the myth i wanted to sort of dispel
was that the school's
performance space is as well resourced
as they are
have any potential to uh replace theater
spaces the problem with them
is the practical one uh if you want to
be a receiving house if you want newton
abbott to attract touring music
attractor in comedy and to be able to
host shows that are runs
then you need to have get-ins that are
early in the day
at noon uh and and uh schools cannot
offer that i cannot think of one
example around the country where a
school would be on the touring circuit
for music or comedy or even theater
so those spaces exist so i i think we
can discount that as being an option
uh equally they could be used for the
local societies but then they're back to
scraps off the table
uh and and taking what they can get
which is what they've had with the alex
uh
for for forever and a day i thought i
think we need to
just focus on remember frank manchin the
guy who built some uh theaters as we
know them the
the the the standard the gold standard
in theaters
came from newton let's uh let's retain
our one opportunity to
to have one of those that that uh that
we can utilize for the community
thank you thank you councillors leader
of the council
thank you chairman as leader of the
council i wish to submit the
motion from the executive and i'm
grateful to all colleagues
for the wide range of views and comments
uh
in this very long debate and i think it
shows the passion which we all feel both
to ensure that newton is dead in
spreading market town
as well as sustaining uh live
performance uh in the tone as well
um i just quickly want to summarize
which is
the point that new chair can i raise a
point of order
what would your point of order be uh are
we not going to vote on the amendment
first before we get a substantive vote
and i would have thought the time for um
the leader to
summarize his comments regarding the
substantive vote it's just prior to that
substantive vote
not prior to the vote on the amendment
councillor patch we will go to the vote
and it will be your amendment first
thank you chairman i haven't spoken on
the amendment i was just reserving all
but i would be very brief chairman
i know everyone's put a lot into this it
was simply to point out there's neil
blaney highlighted
the decisions the committee the council
is asking me today
is about whether on accepting the
funding and i think mr blaney
highlighted
that the discussions continue about the
future of the war
so this is a decision today about um
accepting the funding and i uh i will be
voting against the amendment
because i believe the council's
intention is to carry on discussing with
those groups
about the war so i will be voting
against the amendment
and for the executive motion when that
comes thank you chairman
thank you thank you leader so we're
going to go to the vote now first 34
councillor patch's amendment could you
redefine your amendment please
councillor patch
i i happen to restate it so i'm not
about to redefine it
is that the um the war would be retained
at the back of the
um alexander theater and consequently
the integrity of the alexandria theater
as a performance space
be maintained and and that's second year
by council of coal club
yes so can we go to the vote please beth
councillor austin
councillor austin against
cancer bradford or
cancer bull events against
cancer clarence
against
against cancer david cox against
cancer hugh cox
council of doors four count said you
hearst
against councillor evans
against cancer goodman bradbury
against
that's gordon hook against
cancer jackie hook again
cancer jeffrey against
cancer jefferies against
cancer keeling against
cancer care as well or
cancer mcgregor against
cancer morgan okay cancer malone
or cancer nutley against
cancer nuttall against
cancer parker calm or
cancer patch or cancer
engaged that's linda pedreck
against cancer phipps
against cancer
against cancer rollerson
against cancer russell yes
cancer swain against cancer taylor
against councillor thorne against
councillor against
councillor parker against cancer john
pedreck
against yeah that's lost
thank you so members we revert to the
original recommendation which was
proposed by
councillor jefferies and seconded by
councillor boulevard i believe
so can we go to the vote please
counselor austin
or casa bradford
against council bill evans
cancer clarence what cancer colclough
against cancer connet
paul council david cox or
cancer hugh cox cancer doors
against cancer dewhurst four
councillor evans
a good one bad boy oh that's a gribble
or council haynes
or cancer haze
cats are hocking against
cats are gordon hook
cats are jackie hook ball counselor
jeffrey
against cancer jeffries
councillor keeling four councillor
carswell
or councillor mcgregor or
cancer morgan or cancer malone
get against cats and naturally or
cancer nuttel four that's a propocacon
rain
cancer patch thanks
cancer four council independence
four council fips four
council persa four counts of rolison
paul cancer russell
council swain four cancer taylor
cancer thorne council wrigley
or cancer parker four
councillor john pedreck four
that's carriage chair uh thank you for
that members i'm gonna suggest now that
we take a slightly extended comfort
break of 15 minutes
i make it to 12 35
if you could back it ten to one please
but please switch off your cameras and
microphones before you go
see you in 15 minutes thank you uh mr
chairman i'm gonna have to leave i'm
afraid
okay sorry thank you mike okay
and me okay
uh
my
yes
yes
i see we still have a few gaps members
so we'll just give them another few
minutes
okay if the meeting is still going on at
two o'clock i'll have an appointment
then i may well have to leave the
meeting
um let's hope it doesn't go on that long
thank you hopefully not i'm the same
chairman i've got um
well that quarterbacks two i don't need
to be gone
understood yeah it's okay
beth would you like to carry out a roll
call please see here we go
council austin
president councillor bradford
president cancer bulletin
can't say clarence present
cancer connect okay
council david cox president i'm here
cancer hugh cox present
cancer doors yes i'm here
council dewhurst present cancer evans
present how's it going bradbury
present cancer gribble
cancer haynes present present
cancer hayes
council gordon hook
council jackie hook counselor jeffrey
cancer jeffries president
council keening present
cancer care as well present
cancer mcgregor
cancer morgan council malone
sorry present cats and natalie
cats and nuttle present
council parker khan president cancer
present russell
cancer swain present cancer taylor
present cancer thorne
here council wrigley present
councillor parker present cancer john
pedreck
president thank you for that beth
let's resume now then item nine on the
agenda
recommendation from the standards
committee the new lga
model code of conduct the chair of
standards committee to move the
recommendation
councillor linda pedrick thank you chair
the standards committee excuse me
unanimous unanimously recommends that
the council should adopt
the model code of conduct produced by
the local government association
in place of our current code a copy of
the new code was
included in the committee papers for all
to read
excuse me needless to say adopting the
code will not in itself secure high
standards of council of conduct
further sanctions for breach in the code
are still limited
pending changes to the law we all need
to remember that we are
in control of the standards of conduct
we achieve at team bridge
it is not only our personal
responsibility to ensure
we comply as individuals but also
collectively as full council
to ensure we promote and maintain high
standards of conduct
the model in effect builds upon many of
the principles of good gold
already set out in our code for example
acting with respect not bringing the
council into disrepute
and declaring interest the model code
is more detailed than our own but still
sets out in clear language for the
benefit of the public
and staff as well as councillors what
standards are required of ourselves as
councillors
while the council does not have to adopt
this model code by adopting it we will
be promoting compliance
with the level of standards which have
been set by
an independent body and specifically
drafted for
councillors on behalf of the standards
committee i commend the new code to you
thank you councillor keeling the first
blue hand
thank you mr chairman i'd like to second
that motion
thank you for that any other members
wishing to call councillor patch
thank you chair um i just wanted to ask
the chair of the standards committee
if the standards committee feel that
there would be a need for additional
training
um um if this um updated code were
adopted
training for members that is
that could be arranged and that probably
would be um a good thing to do
thank you for that counsellor patch
chairman i'm sorry for my late return
that's it's always a pleasure to see you
george thank you
thank you go through the doors
hi thank you uh just one question
actually uh
and uh just for the benefit of the
public actually so that there's clear
understanding of what was
being adopted or being proposed to be
adopted uh
do do these uh new standards procedures
uh outline conflicts of interest and do
they
do they stretch further than the current
ones and do they reflect those the
the government would have uh the
conflicts of interest should be declared
for
family members as well as spouses
i will ask the monetary officer to
answer that question
um thank you madam chair and chair of
council
um yes they do actually they go further
than our existing code in so far as they
talk about interests that
apply to family um
close associates and also relatives
so yes they do go wider but if you
actually read the code which is the best
thing to do
you will see that it covers all the sort
of interests which one would reasonably
expect a councillor to declare
and at all times in any event there are
general obligations
which obviously seek to secure that
councils are acting always in the public
interest and not their private interests
key themes which underline the whole of
the code in any event
mcgregor uh thank you
i just wanted to note that the emotion
submitted by
counselor eden that's on the agenda um
goes a little bit further i think in
terms of outlining
what should be considered councillor
mcgregor i'm sorry we we haven't come to
that agenda
today i'm discussing this agenda point
chair and i think it's quite important
to
to understand why i'm mentioning the the
yes please
um is that perhaps that part of the
question that was covered by councillor
doors
would be answered by that motion that is
up on the agenda later
thank you
you can't see any more blue hands so
could we go to the vote please beth
councillor austin or cancer bradford
can you um chair can you outline it
again please
can you can you say it before we vote
sorry
what we're voting on this is a
recommendation from the standards
committee that the new
lga model of code of conduct is adopted
by this council
okay the the actual details of the code
of comments
it was embedded in in the electronic
version of the
of the agenda it's 17-page document
you waiting for me are you well i i yes
i don't know if you wanted to come back
at all
um against no oh
okay sorry because yeah
david cox or councillor hugh cox
oh cats cancer doors against
cancer due herst four cancer evans
four cancer goodman bradbury
or cancer gribble
chairman i have to abstain because of my
late return
cancer haynes
cancer hayes
cancer gordon hook paul
councillor jackie hook
councillor jeffrey laura captain
jeffries
paul councillor jenks
apologies he's not here uh cancer
keeling
or cancer care as well
oh cancer mcgregor
or cats and morgan
councillor malone yesterday
captain natalie four that's a nuttel
four council parker khan
cancer patch abstain
cancer pit council
thought cancer phipps
four camps of persister or
councillor ronnison or
councillor russell oh
oh and if i may we had a note that um
councillor hayes internet had dropped
off which is why he isn't here
thank you councillor parker or
cancer john pedreck
thank you for that item 10 on the agenda
procedures committee the leader to
present the report and the purpose
leader of council thank you very much
chairman colleagues will be familiar
that
uh in the past the council has dealt
with constitutional amendments
usually through a working group of group
leaders and some other members
which has been a working policy
arrangement and
informal arising from
various issues raised over the past
months
uh we've looked at a different scheme
and this proposal sets out the creation
of a formal procedures committee which
would make
like any other committee of the council
and withdrawn for our um
foundations on this the procedures
committee
which operates at devon county council
has ever looked far but we've found a
system that works
works well members will have read the
report and i
move the recommendations i've sent out
chairman
thank you so proposed by the leader and
second deployed councillor dewhurst
council of boulevard uh thank you i was
going to also propose to second that uh
agenda and i think an excellent point
within this um
suggestion is the inclusion of
the minority party um to make sure that
the balance
exists that our existing structures
wouldn't allow
so i'm happy to see that the three
members of
union says no have the opportunity to
put somebody onto this committee
i welcome that as they as a move thank
you
thank you any other members wishing to
comment on that
and the case will go to the vote in
place beth
council austin for cancer bradford
that's obvious sorry i couldn't
um unmute it
abstain thank you
counselor clarence for
answer connect paul
that's david cox all very welcome
cathy hugh cox
cats to doors staying
cancer dewhurst or
cancer evans or
council government bradbury or
council gribble or cancer haynes
or cancer gordon hook
four councillor jackie hook
ball councillor jeffrey laura
casa jeffries oh
council keeling four
that's the care as well oh
cancer mcgregor or
captain morgan oh that's
my lane abstain
that's in natalie or councilman
paul casa parker come
counselor patch what
that's appeared oh
that's a linda pedreck four cancer
phipps
or counselor four
council rollerson or councillor russell
councillor swain four councillor taylor
or cancer thorne
yeah cancer wrigley
or cancer parker or
cancer john pedreck oh children if i
i haven't got my own mute off i'm er
well thank you thank you very much
that's carrie thank you
councillor your blue hand is still
raised
are you
that's okay it's inadvertent yes
i know you've got a something like an
ice cream cone
yes okay um
item 11 on the agenda i'm going to ask
democratic services and legal a question
on this one because
this is a notice of motion from
councillor eden councillor eden is not
available to present her notice of
motion
so would it be acceptable democratic
services and legal
if we defer this item to a future
meeting
so so i can answer that if that helps um
you can if obviously full council agreed
to do that
in that case i would like to propose
through the chair
that we defer this this notice of motion
as councillor even is not here to
present it
um to a future meeting
would somebody like to second that
please
second it thank you second if i cancel
the cops so can we go to the vote on
that please
oh but sorry councillor mcgregor you
wish to speak
yeah it was just to say would it be
worth deferring it direct to the newly
created committee
at the first opportunity rather than
deferring it next to the export council
that will short-circuit the process a
little bit and get it in front of the
people that need to get in front of it
council mcgregor i i think that as
council region is not here to
to present the notice of motion and
her in her email to me she requested
that it went to the procedures committee
but i think generally the officers and
the councillors feel
that this should actually go to the
standards board so i think
with the absence of councillor even i
think we need now to suggest that it is
deferred
so can we go to the vote please
counselor austin
four councillor bradford
or cancer bill event or
cancer clarence councillor connect
cancer david cox cancer hugh cox
cancer doors or councillor dew hurst
fort cancer evans four
council government bradbury or
cancer gribble or cancer haynes
or cancer gordon hook
four that's a jackie hook four
cancer
to
jeffrey
council keeling four cancer care as well
oh council mcgregor
four perhaps a person
four councillor allison
four cancer russell
council swain four councillor taylor
poor a thorn yeah
cancer wrigley paul council parker
four council john patrick yeah
thank you for that sarah thank you so
that brings us more that's the end of
our meeting today members just one thing
to update you on is there is an
extraordinary council meeting
on the 4th of may so that's at 9 30 and
the purpose of that meeting if you're
not already aware
is to consider a report regarding the
decarbonisation plans
for forward house so i look forward to
seeing you on the 4th of may
goodbye everyone
thank you thank you very much